foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
oh
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too
okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
bag of mangoes mango art mangoes like a
free boxy that's it eight or eleven
bucks
mangoes
[Music]
[Music]
mango
the Wisconsin crowd identified from the
mango
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're just joining us Rudy Giuliani
is sweating his face off explaining to
us why Trump really won the election
again inspectors every state
almost every approve this it's going
away go on for eternity is this a skit
the only thing left is to prevent a dead
person that could have been not filled
out wait he's saying there was a dead
person in the envelope
Rudy's about to have actual drops of
sweat coming off of his brow I mean is
this a normal amount I don't know how
hot it is in the room but this something
seems very wrong here we'll be in the
lawsuit that comes out duties melting
Arizona is a state that we're looking at
very very carefully strongly looking at
it I would say we're probably I assume
she's working but she's working for them
I'd like to read them all to you but I
don't have the time you should have had
the time and energy to go look for them
foreign
like it's my job to defend the president
Michigan Wisconsin is he bleeding did
you see is he bleeding from his ear what
on Earth was that
to find out if I'm fine is that hair dye
is to look at the lawsuits in order to
do it it looks like blood but in the
material oh my God it's everywhere
[Music]
and there are other aspects of this
fraud on the morning of November
someone's got to get him a napkin they
were going to count
I've never seen anything like this what
on Earth it's getting onto his shirt now
Michigan and in Wisconsin any jury would
accept because they heard this evidence
that somebody had this plan that's just
insane maybe that was always the plan
looks like sap from an oak tree or a
maple tree it looks like someone's
making syrup to the city describes that
to you oh my God it's all over his face
he's gonna need a towel evidence I don't
know guys it's sounding like Trump won
isn't it based on this
oh man that is really a classic welcome
everybody we are almost 20.
four hours into the the liberations by
the jury
in the Kyle Rittenhouse case MSNBC has
been kicked out of the Court by the
judge
uh we're going to talk about that
um unrest seems to so two days ago there
was some unrest in Kenosha
and then yesterday it was pretty calm
today things are getting a little wacky
in Kenosha and we're going to get to
that in a little bit we also are
monitoring the increasingly compelling
trial over the killing of Ahmad Arbury
let's listen just to a little bit
there's actually a big fight going on
right now outside the presence of the
jury
defendant is seeking
um
that was a broad brush Mr Goff it was
so I guess we are noting it for the
record we are not even Severance issue
for the record and to be more specific
if the defense I I I don't know what
you're doing but if the defense is going
to call Diego Perez who I had thought
the state was calling but they decided
not to call I had thought the defense
was calling maybe they're not calling
but if they're going to put him up and
the state's going to back door in
vigilante issues involving the
co-defendants or after the fact
conspiracies before the state does that
on cross-examination I think we need to
take that up outside the presence of the
jury
well the court will take that matter I
don't even take them out or other bottom
of the pot duly noted
let's go ahead and take it to my
recently all right so they're going to
be on recess for the time being
um okay so what so first of all the
mustache is gone my friends
the mustache is gone
I wasn't kidding around when I said if
we don't get 50 members it's gonna go
people thought oh sir it's just that no
no no no it was very very real and the
mustache is gone I have duly noted it
and I will be taking it um under
advisement okay I don't even know where
to start I guess I I want to just flag
something for you guys you know a lot of
times people come to me and they say Sir
who is your favorite guest that you've
ever interviewed and they expect me to
say some well-known politician or
whatever the case may be and it rarely
rarely is now with 1500 interviews under
our belt
it's there's not one favorite interview
today's interview on my podcast is one
of my favorite interviews that I've ever
done I interviewed theoretical physicist
Jeffrey West who is 80 years old now
he is a very nice British guy
and he wrote the book scale one of my
favorite non-fiction books that I've
ever read the interview is fantastic
it's on today's podcast we're gonna have
an extended version video up on
YouTube's uh I don't know when I'd have
to talk to producer Pat I don't know
when he's it's maybe probably tomorrow
or who the hell knows uh sometime soon
but
um absolutely one of my favorite one of
my favorite interviews so that's going
to be
that's what it is okay I see people in
the chat asking about twitch Subs zero
we are banned from twitch we are now uh
hold on seven eight nine ten we are ten
days into a 30-day ban I've appealed the
ban they've not even adjudicated the ban
that's why it says twitch Sub Zero we
had a thousand paid subscribers on
Twitch and we lost them okay
um
let's start with uh oh okay we're
keeping the coupon code uncharged
pickles uncharged piccolos until we have
a verdict in the Written House trial I'm
thinking as I've said before we may
shift over to the trial over the killing
of Ahmad Arbury when The Written House
trial is done I'm thinking then we might
switch to the coupon code Colonel
Sanders and it's a reference to this
moment in the Arbury case if the
question folks came in here dressed like
Colonel Sanders with white masks sitting
in the back I mean that would be
so
so anyway uh
I'm thinking that the next um
the next coupon code may be Colonel
Sanders related now let me give you guys
a little bit of the flavor of what's
happening today in Kenosha here is
approach I guess it's a protester it's
never really clear what they're
protesting this is a guy with a hoodie
very suspicious we learned in the um in
the George Zimmerman trial hoodies are
very very suspicious and this guy's
wearing one he has a sign which says
black crime matters and here he this is
this is so good uh Tara lemuse says
outside the Kenosha courthouse now a
protester wants the world to know his
views on The Written House trial through
a poorly penned nonsensical sign and
repeated use of the n-word to mask his
own ignorance
uh okay so this is what's going this is
just one scene outside the courthouse
because Richard Pryor has an album
called that [ __ ] crazy Mike Tyson
says the N word
depending on your race you can see the
[Music]
so if you hear the word [ __ ] and
somebody's around the corner you have to
look and see who the person was that
said it to find out if it was a weapon
to find out if you're hurt come on oh my
God a regular Bertrand Russell I need to
hear this guy's philosophical views Bill
Cosby said why don't black people quit
smacking their kids quit saying
[ __ ] and we calling each other
[ __ ]
yeah
well because I like to see the process
of how it works
what what exactly is he seeing standing
outside with a Sign by the way you could
see more on my stream than just being
there
the process of course works like this
there's a judge there's a jury there's
evidence there's Witnesses and there's
cross-examination more than that what do
you want
this is the reason that aliens won't
talk to us oh boy
now we're off the rails huh like before
it wasn't now we're off the rails
so
um
this is
um
I guess it's just mental illness I
thought maybe it was something else but
I guess it's just mental illness okay
here's another perspective of what's
going on in Kenosha
this one is Commander Hulk of the Royal
Black Panther Party of Chicago he
weighed in on the trial
and they're good Justice
running around we can allow people to go
around playing vigilante in this killing
people you know that's not right and
we're going to make a difference we're
going to stand up and we're going to
start right here and make a change right
there what do you think is going to be
the outcome of the
hope for the best respect the worst we
know the deck is that with 13 results
all of them play golf together that's
how it is
terrible
and they need to stop right here have
you heard a lot of discourse in other
areas like Chicago and kind of around
the country about this
all right so there's there's another
perspective just to giving everybody
different perspectives
um that's Commander Hulk of the Royal
Black Panther Party of Chicago and then
the other oh hold on I just want to
monitor what's happening uh we're sort
of getting to a critical moment oh let
me mention a little bit about this so as
you can see here the counter is at 2204.
the jury is now in its 23rd hour of
deliberations it is also 2 51 PM Kenosha
time
I spoke to the same defense attorneys
I've been speaking to this morning
um and they told me about this thing
that will sometimes happen where if the
jury feels as though it's close and it
starts to get to three four o'clock
sometimes they go until five sometimes
they go until six local time unless that
sometimes they'll request to just go
until 9 10 that's why you sometimes see
these verdicts much later
um
sometimes if they feel like they're
close or they figured out some charges
anything can kind of happen in these
last 90 minutes because they might say
we probably need to come back tomorrow
but maybe we can just real quick
finalize the last one and that can
sometimes mean guilty sometimes it can
be not guilty you sometimes have almost
like which is horrible that it goes this
way but sometimes you'll have
negotiations where if someone if they've
agreed on guilty on one charge and
they're just arguing arguing arguing
about something else they want to end
today you might almost you might
sometimes see these sort of like
jockeying that takes place it's not good
it's not a good thing
uh but the last 90 minutes when you're
three days in
sometimes attorneys I spoke to start to
get a little bit what is going to happen
here because do they really want to come
back another day tomorrow maybe they do
maybe they don't but we're into hour 23.
this is the killing of Ahmad Arbury case
uh but there they have the verdict watch
counter and then we also are monitoring
um this is the law and crime Network PBS
has also been covering it now people are
asking me David what's this about MSNBC
getting kicked out I'm gonna play the
video for you what this is about is it
became known that someone known to be a
producer for MSNBC
reportedly ran a red light yesterday
following the jury bus believed to be to
try to identify jurors okay here we go
a person who identified himself as James
G Morrison
who claimed that he was a producer with
NBC News
and played for MSNBC
[Music]
um
and under the supervision
of a person what's going on
oh okay uh under the supervision of
someone named Irene Bion in New York uh
for MSNBC
the police when they stopped him because
he was following in the distance of
about
black and went through a red light
pulled him over and inquired of him what
was going on and he gave that in from
[Music]
stated that he had been instructed by Ms
Bayonne in New York to follow the jury
bus
[Music]
uh the matter is under further
investigation at this point
um
and the media has asked questions about
it that's the latest I have
[Music]
um
and he was ticketed for uh violating a
traffic control signal
he's not here today from what I'm told
and
um
I have instructed that no one from MSNBC
news will be permitted in this building
for the duration of this trial this is a
very serious matter and I don't know
what the ultimate truth of it is but
absolutely it would go without
thinking that someone who is following
us
a jury bus that is a very ex that's
extremely serious matter and we'll be
all right so MSNBC has been kicked out
of the room that's uh that's what's
going on there I did want to see if
there were any other Kenosha videos that
were relevant to our interests
um
okay so here's another a lot of people
bringing weapons by the oh can I say
something
you guys remember how evidence kept
being presented exhibits from BG on the
scene I never made the connection BG on
the scene who filmed a lot of the the
core exhibits in the trial
is Brendan guten schwager who follows me
and who I follow and we've known about
his work for it's I just never made I
didn't I don't know BG on the scene
what's that
um it's Brendan guttenschwager so anyway
he continues to be in Kenosha here's
another guy now you might say wait David
was this the guy yesterday
um who was carrying a gun too close at
the courthouse no this is a different
person so this is another guy being
taken out
[Music]
there
total chaos
[Music]
and then he goes to the Paddy Wagon
that's an old school Paddy Wagon huh
[Music]
very very powerful images
and again what this goes to for me is
the continued fear that regardless of
the verdict and honestly almost in
particular if there's a mixed verdict
where it's some guilty some not guilty
and everyone ends up pissed off
um I'm worried that there's gonna be uh
I'm worried that there's going to be
chaos
uh but they got this guy so the city of
Kenosha police taking this mail
into custody
and very powerfully checking him for a
variety of weapons
and uh
see ultimately
well I guess they put him in the back I
don't even know oh they just walk away
okay they don't even put him in the
Paddy Wagon
yep so there's that that's um that's
that's going on there
okay welcome everybody we are on day
three of jury deliberations I want to
say thank you to Michael gunzer and
Darcy and Nathan Mercer who just signed
up on my website and our new members one
two and three today the coupon code
uncharged pickles uncharged piccolos
will be valid through the verdict please
sign up on my website joinpakman.com
yesterday you find people killed my
mustache because we did not get to 50
members and I gleefully shaved it off
power shaved uh yesterday and it is gone
uh but maybe we will go right back with
a reverse mustache I shave only the
mustache sort of a kind of back country
look or something else something we can
certainly consider you can also make
pledges on patreon they count double
those will count as two
which is very very exciting
um okay
always Paddy Wagon and anti-iri I had no
idea I've never heard that before I had
no idea
Paddy Wagon official offensive
oh no it was found
it was found not offensive
Irish Central reports it is not
offensive
all right well anyway I don't want to
offend anybody
I don't even know what what is that is
it like St Patty's Day I don't even know
I know nothing about Irish anything I
don't I know nothing about it I love the
Irish
um
oh we just got banned in Ireland oh my
God
canceled okay
um let me say I'm gonna get to Super
chats I want to say one other thing
I've been I've been pre-promoting that
today I would be interviewing Andrew
yang
the interview just took place it was
great to catch up with Andrew I want to
tease something from the interview
I asked Andrew Yang's new thing with his
forward party is ranked Choice voting
fixed campaign Finance to grow third
parties fine I asked Andrew Yang do you
welcome the support of white
supremacists as long as they support
rank Choice voting and campaign Finance
reform
he paused and he thought for a while
about the answer
and then he answered it
okay
very interesting moment in my new
interview with Andrew Yang it's going to
be published next week it's going to be
published next week very interesting and
compelling interview
I'm seeing an audio looping on your
Facebook live stream I don't know that I
can do anything about that
um I see 700 people watching on Facebook
I could turn off and back on the stream
but oftentimes like 99 of the time when
people report technical issues to me
it's it's just you gotta refresh
um
so we'll see about that okay
all right uh JD straight shot says have
Hawk
can someone please send David the ray
gun sound David Destiny went on a rant
about you yesterday deer season opens
Saturday can we get Tucker Carlson on
obstruction of justice David any plans
to discuss the trial further with
Destiny yeah you know here's the thing I
I'm glad to talk to Destiny anytime I
did see let me see if I can find it I
saw that he tweeted a very very ugly
attack on me
[Music]
um
here it is this is this is Stephen
Kenneth Destiny Bonnell II it's insane
that he has this take and he's been
watching the whole trial what levels of
copium are people on holy [ __ ] and I
reported GTFO now this was a joke
honestly I don't care what Stephen
Kenneth Destiny benel II thinks about my
opinions of the trial uh I don't know if
he's been watching the whole trial or
he's been watching Clips or people are
sending him weird stuff someone wrote to
me and said David
um this is the problem with the Stephen
Kenneth Destiny benel II Community where
if you have like a five percent
disagreement
and I don't know what level of
disagreement we even have they turn on
you and it's all crazy a couple people
wrote to me and said David Stephen is
clearly autistic like in the sense that
this is not a normal way to relate to
someone that you're friends with
or whatever
um and I don't know anything about that
if that's the case then you know I don't
for me it's all kind of just like
whatever
um and I'm gonna be in LA in a couple
weeks if Destiny still lives there I'd
be glad to go and get brunch again and
he can get four side orders of different
pork products like he did last time I it
like for me it's I am not having any
conversations in the real world so to
speak about Kyle Rittenhouse so for me
it's like even if we have a 30
disagreement a 50 disagreement I don't
care I don't care I'm not talking about
the ritten house trial in the real world
you know what I'm saying like it just
doesn't bother me so if Stephen kind of
Destiny benell II actually is pissed at
me now okay if he's not if it's if it's
whatever if it's a result of autism is I
I just don't care you know it's just
like whatever if he wants to chat with
me I'll talk to him if he doesn't I
won't if his audience likes me great if
they don't too bad I'm just doing my
thing and everybody kind of has their
opinion the only thing that would bother
me and again if autism is a factor you
wouldn't be able to read these cues
I don't want bad faith attributed to me
because I've been perfectly transparent
nothing I'm doing you know I saw
somewhere on the dgg subreddit someone
said it's clear Pacman doesn't even
believe the things he's saying now
that's a bit much you know one of the
things I do on this program is I just
tell you what I think and you might
disagree you might it's not like some
crafted oh hold on I gotta ban a couple
people here
one
well I guess just one
okay and you know I know that oh I could
play up the drama and that way it would
get clicks I'm so bored by the drama
it's just boring Stephen wants to chat
great personal attacks I'm not
interested you know attacks of bad faith
in particular I wouldn't tolerate but it
sounds like we just we both think not
guilty on the big charges I think if
there's a case for guilty it would be on
Rosenbaum and it might be a lesser
included am I a terrible person for
thinking I mean come on guys give me a
break let's let's be adults
okay
what else am I missing here oh thank you
to Dez who just made a patreon pledge
those count double and that puts us at
five also thanks to Kaylee Payton Kaylee
Payton just signed up on my website with
the coupon code
and his new member number six today
thank you Kaylee I really really very
much appreciate that okay other Super
Chat sign guy is everything wrong with
America agree
I'm offended I've we've been here all
along
okay just want everyone to notice
YouTube has started to remove dislikes
no one can see dislikes yeah they told
us weeks ago or maybe even months ago
they were going to do that
on behalf of aliens I'm offended
um lawyers at recchietta law yeah I
don't care it's right wing you can go
watch it if you want what did I miss
Shapiro he's not racist y'all are
overreacting twitch Sub-Zero new Mortal
Kombat character thank you sir you do
get great work sir who is this 14 year
old Pac-Man look-alike without a
mustache David you are looking like a
beta b-a-e oh I see what you did there
very good all right appreciate that can
the MSNBC incident be grounds for a
mistrial I don't imagine how what I
really hope doesn't happen What I really
hope doesn't happen is that the judge
waits to rule on the mistrial until
after the verdicts and if there's guilty
verdicts then the judge goes mistrial
everybody mistrial
um that would be insane and I hope that
it doesn't happen
thank you for covering the trial
throwing five bucks your way since you
lost Facebook and twitch Revenue thanks
Jeff regardless of the verdict can we
please avoid violence that's my hope
that's my hope
um oh yeah we were in the middle
hold on a second
around noon yeah we were in the middle
of looking at some video from what's
going on in Kenosha we saw the Black
Panther Party Guy we saw N word white
guy we saw someone taken away in a
police vehicle we watched this one
already
um let me see what else I had for you
okay so here I think this is the same
incident here so we don't need to review
that
this was yesterday
hey remember this guy this guy was that
witness that right wing nut he now says
he's getting death threats immediately
when I got off the stand I already had
DMS in my Instagram and on Twitter and
on Facebook people telling me to kill
myself uh saying I defended a murderer
people sending me pictures with human
beings with Targets on their back I mean
that's pretty obvious and also people
saying I hope you get shot uh so I mean
it's it's now interestingly those aren't
death threats really like as someone who
has dealt with death threats if I send
to the I've taught like I've sent
probably 50 death threats to the FBI
um
guys people complaining about focus and
blurriness it it's on your end guys
it's on your end it's what is happening
it's like when people tell me I'm muted
and it's like I'm doing an hour I've
been speaking for an hour I'm obviously
not muted
um
saying kill yourself the FBI does not
consider a death threat in my personal
experience and saying I hope you die or
get shot the FBA actually the FBI
actually also doesn't consider that a
death threat in in my experience it's
just it's interesting to hear how the
prosecutor was trying to discredit me
saying that I am biased because I'm
saying antifa and BLM are writing in the
footage because they are that's not
biased but these these threats just
prove who these people are they're
they're damn there was weird because he
hasn't actually like I I think everybody
should take threats very seriously
and I've told the story of when an FBI
agent actually drove out to
someone's house in uh should I even say
what state you know kind of like in the
Vermont New Hampshire Main area
they were not saying David I hope you
kill yourself you know that it was very
very different
um
I don't know nothing peaceful about
Kenosha even right now there's a reason
why they called 500 National Guard out
there right now because they're
preparing for more riots there was
nothing peaceful about Kenosha at all
from the very beginning I was there day
one two days before Kyle Rittenhouse
even showed up to Kenosha and Dan you
want to know who showed up with rifles
first it was the rioters I have it on
film Drew H live everybody could go see
it on my Twitter right they say Jewish
live that's weird all right so that's
that um this was yesterday the
mccloskeys uh this is more of this armed
guy getting detained
it's it's getting very very chaotic
there more McCloskey stuff we don't need
to look at that this was from yesterday
um okay so I think that that's basically
everything in terms of what's happening
there
uh okay yeah so we'll keep an eye on on
new stuff happening in Kenosha but for
the time being uh just a few different
things
we would just renew the emotion for
directed verdict of acquittal we made at
the end of the state's case same
arguments I won't repeat any of them
here but I want to adopt all of them and
apply them here at the end all right so
this continues and we are uh now well
into very much into the 23rd hour of
deliberations at this point in time
it is uh it it's getting there we're
really getting into
serious deliberations serious excuse me
choking now
thank you I want to say thanks to
Christopher Hill who just signed up on
my website with the coupon code
uncharged pickles and his new member
number seven also thanks to Sully divad
who just made a patreon pledge those
count double today which puts us at nine
okay other super chats coming in a
number of the pickle thanks for very
strong trial coverage sir The Adventures
of jump kick man and bicep boy did you
see Matt Gates wants to hire pickle
house as an intern I did anyone
surprised there's more police and
National Guard at the courthouse than
there was in DC January 6th yeah
David do you think that because Kyle
incited the incident might get might rid
him of the ability to claim self-defense
um that's not the way it's being
that's not been a factor in the trial in
any serious way
on behalf of neurodivergent half Irish
people you were absolved of all
cancellations from Destiny or otherwise
okay let's see what's going on here the
jury to return so more preliminary
matters that will have to be addressed
tomorrow Nema I want to bring you back
in tell us more if you would about any
surprise or what you thought of the fact
that again seven Witnesses present okay
so they're talking they're talking about
the other case
um hello from Denver is the anger
surrounding this case really to do with
Rittenhouse or a symptom of our partisan
divide I think you know it could be both
and other things as well the longer this
goes the more I think hung jury says Bay
photo that is one possibility remember
hung jury you have they have to be hung
on each and every count so you could
have four verdicts and one count of hung
jury we don't know how many counts are
currently holding them up
um how does someone make the case antifa
was there I thought they weren't even
organized I don't I mean it's that's
sort of neither here nor there big
picture
um
okay let's get to some voicemails folks
the voicemails are just pouring pouring
pouring in it's actually shocking how
many there are let's just start with one
from Whitney while we continue to
explore others
if Ben Shapiro wins the court cases
where they're going to say that
vaccination is not mandatory I'm blaming
the court system like I would never
what's what's been doing I don't even
know what that's about uh
the media is wrong
um at least the left-wing media
um MSNBC particularly taking the Kyle
winhouse situation anybody else finding
themselves really bored by Troy York's
commentary hey thank me um
the woman at MSNBC
um she didn't humiliate Chris Christie
she just showed away in her typical host
um her name is whatever
um Jimmy from Philly called in it looks
like quite a screed
David give me some silly White
uh you know I think you [ __ ] up on
your coverage of this trial I think you
really did
and I speak to these kids some of these
kids came raided me after one of your uh
live streams and uh
disillusioned what you managed they
don't like the way what you're saying
about Kyle they you know well they think
that they could go watch something else
one of the weirdest things I find in the
online space that we all
living is
if you really don't like my show
why waste time watching it and then
calling other people about me
like there's lots of shows I don't like
I just don't watch them
am I crazy I think you're [ __ ] nuts
they're they're they're like what
happened to him since 2017 and [ __ ]
yeah you went too far with the Trump
shot you're on the wrong side of
everything damn it you really are I
should be saying Kyle is a hero and
Trump is a hero I mean this kid is a
[ __ ] hero he is okay is it DC we're
off that's uh that's bandworthy the Kyle
is a hero in all caps is bandworthy so
we're gonna move on from that
let's see what else we've got the
voicemails are really really really
pouring in here
hi David
David
jury
it would be a fair trial or would it be
definitely a mistrial because if it were
a hung jury all the jurors would be men
right
oh man that's that's not bad
hey David I heard a Super Chat come in
uh about the Rittenhouse trial they
asked do you think that since Kyle
incited the incident could his claim to
self-defense be invalidated and you said
that was not a serious aspect of trial I
have to beg to differ I believe the
whole point of the video where Kyle
points the gun at the zaminski's oh yeah
yeah no see so I I mean something else
what I interpreted the Super Chat to
mean and what people have been emailing
me is saying
given the fact that Kyle chose to go at
all and placed himself there with a gun
can that automatically blanket
invalidate any claim of self-defense
that's what I understood of course the
caller is right
very much at issue with Rosenbaum is if
Kyle Rittenhouse leveled the firearm
first that's absolutely a factor so I I
may have not been clear in what I said I
may have not been clear in what I said
and I apologize about that
um
let's see what else we've got
hey David I have an interesting take on
the Kyle writtenhouse trial or case
I think personally that Kyle should pull
a power move right now and at this stage
fire his attorney he should do that
immediately
um uh citing their incompetence and then
hiring another attorney from Florida
uh specifically Sarasota Florida okay
and then that is Sarasota what attorney
well uh we'll tell the judge that his
client Kyle already didn't help is
mentally unfit to stand trial uh the
judge will probably agree and the case
will be settled and the trial will be uh
will be free from our charges I
all right well if there's any lawyers in
the chat who actually want to comment on
that I'm I'm glad to um I'm glad to hear
from you
hi David
I love your channel uh first time caller
in I was there with you on 1 6. I
watched your coverage all day that day
it was uh great that you did great
coverage today thank you this trial is
absolutely crazy
um I could really see this going either
way and I just wanted to appreciate your
daily coverage of it I've been following
with you and trying to participate in
your comments and
I just really think that uh you know uh
your your conflict with Stephen Kenneth
Bonnell the second Destiny uh you know
don't don't burn the bridge uh you guys
have differing opinions but I respect
you both anyway I love you David it's
funny everybody talking about burning
the bridge I'm burning nothing I'm on
the I'm just on one side of the bridge
and other people it's crazy to be
shooting at the bridge setting explosive
charges on the bridge sending Molotov
cocktails at the bridge standing on the
other side trying to cut the bridge and
then saying to me who's just standing
David you really shouldn't burn this
bridge you know you really shouldn't do
that I'm not doing anything guys please
okay other voicemails
hey David do you think if the jurors are
getting close to a verdict tonight
they'll be lucky enough to get some hot
food for dinner perhaps even calzones
I don't know if I could be that lucky
yeah I know that's a real question
anyway how are the calzones I won
I won I wonder if they would be able to
come in and say we want to continue
deliberation but we are going to need
warm food at noon warm food around noon
yeah
um we'll watch for that we will watch
for that
um okay let's let's reset because we do
have almost 10 000 people here and um I
want to explain everything that's going
on right now
The Rittenhouse jury deliberation is
halfway through the 23rd hour they have
completed 22 hours of deliberation and
they are 32 minutes into their 23rd hour
of deliberation that's how we have
assessed how time works okay
it is
very plausible given that it is now 3 20
PM roughly in Kenosha
that if they don't really make progress
in the next hour to 75 minutes that may
be it for today and it would be another
day without a verdict
without a verdict
second option
if in 75-ish minutes when they would
normally wrap
they feel like they're getting close
and they want to keep deliberating they
can ask the court to continue doing that
I believe that they would be able to ask
about dinner all right how was the KFC
and they could they could continue
deliberating Into the Night
um I think that
it is likely
um
that if they are not feeling as though
they can definitely agree on all the
charges today
it's probably going into tomorrow and
then it's going to start over again
tomorrow and then they will be into hour
or you know 25 or 26 or something like
that the vague idea of not guilty on
everything
in my mind
is all but in the trash in the toilet
you know wherever it is that you want to
say it is people are flushing toilets 10
times 15 times that we can forget about
um that being said it could still end up
being not guilty on everything but the
idea of everyone comes in and we're just
like they never should have even brought
this case
uh obviously not uh not not the
situation that's happening here
um so we should know about that in a
little bit and we're monitoring we're
really monitoring everything there's
nothing more that we could be monitoring
other than I did want to get video from
outside the courthouse because it has
been getting a little dicier there let
me see here
um
let me see if I can find ourselves a
good
oh there there might not be anyone
streaming outside right now
no I'm not seeing it
hmm
let's see if we just search for Kenosha
and live streams so we've got the PBS
feed
oh hold on I think I did find one here
ah okay this is ruptly which I think is
like Russian propaganda but it's just um
it's just a single shot so I guess we'll
take it I I do try not to use this
nonsense but
see what else we've got
yeah Okay so we've got we're keeping an
eye out for what's going on relatively
small crowd for now uh the pan-african
flag is still there
um one guy again another guy today
arrested
for having a gun very very close
so we are we are standing by for that
okay a few other super chats David
reconciliation package might pass today
okay we will look at that sir how will
the defend dance elements of medical
play into the verdict I don't know
unless Destiny actually wants to talk
about it instead of attacking people on
Twitter David's doing the right thing by
letting it fly over his head go pack
David do you think there's any way
Kyle's mother can be charged with
criminal negligence for her pardon
dropping off Kyle did she drop Kyle off
now it's not clear to me I know that he
was planning on getting a ride with
someone back
I I don't know I don't know
at this point I'm not even it's I don't
I'm just not sure Dan says warm food
around noon took up millibytes of the
trial megabyte
it was a four megabyte video millabyte
titled
so sorry you have to deal with hysterics
and weirdness tensions are high people
say whatever your coverage has been even
handed measured and fair and I
appreciate it that's a powerful message
of peace and love any idea where jurors
are going to the bathroom we know where
they're not going to the bathroom
whatever you do make sure you go to the
bathroom
is somewhere other than
exactly
snack squad on YouTube is streaming
outside okay let's pull that up
uh snack Squad
snack Squad
ah okay
it's a bit of a chaotic shot
but we'll we'll keep I mean it's like
it looks like about 10 frames per second
not even maybe five
um okay so we're watching all of it guys
and we may hear from the judge in a bit
um we're watching all of it I want to
say a huge thank you to
I want I I is this trying to get me into
saying something I shouldn't
okay
uh
I want to say thank you to moon pie we
okay
and Austin Green Austin Green for
signing up on my website
joinpakman.com very very much appreciate
that guys thank you
David why was Jesus such a thirst trap
that I can't comment on
I predict a hungry jury verdict David
sir any debates lined up in the future
now the Charlie Kirk people reached out
to me about being on that show but I
gotta go to Phoenix for it and they
don't pay you anything
so uh I don't know
I don't know it's just
you know it's like three days to do an
hour debate for no money
uh I don't know
they say they're a non-profit which is
they're like we're non-profit so we
can't pay you any money like what you're
a non-profit that has so much funding
from all these millionaires
um
he's not actually in Phoenix he's in
Arizona I'm just saying Phoenix just to
be you know
okay David maybe if you cheat the
logarithms you can get back on Twitch
you should ask Kyle's lawyers how to do
that yeah that's not a bad idea
it's not a bad idea sir how is the KFC
pretty good huh I I thought it was great
yeah I know I'm not going to do this
whole KFC thing again I've not had fast
food for 20 years many of you don't know
that I've never mentioned that before
but um I did when a KFC opened near me
about 10 12 years ago I went and I got a
crispy strip meal with mashed coleslaw
and a buttermilk biscuit
okay
let me just ban a few more people guys
thank you
well thank you very much everybody I
appreciate that
let's get to a few other voicemails here
hey David my name is Ronnie
I'm from Illinois and I've been watching
all kinds of this [ __ ] on each different
aspect
and watching the live chat
I honestly think
it's not going to go in the favor of Cal
Rittenhouse a lot of people are saying
jumping
uh a lot of people are saying he's not
guilty so what in my opinion 100 percent
I think
if it's voting like America is
hopefully we'll get a guilty verdict
thanks for everything you do love you
man peace out I'm not sure I even
understand that but I very very much
appreciate it
Trump was right David
people are flushing their toilets 10 and
15 times because of giant logarithms
okay
David
my pickle charger is broken
I now have a refrigerator full of
uncharged pickles
that guy's pretty good
hey David uh first time a voicemail
caller just wondering if you have any
advice on speaking clearly because uh I
found you're definitely the most clear
and concise speaker I've probably
ever heard run a news show
I just want to know if you have any
advice on that on how to clearly get
your point across uh
and uh thanks for the shield good day
you know I really don't you you don't
you don't seem to have any problem
speaking clearly so I don't even know
that you necessarily need my advice to
be perfectly Frank you seem to be making
a lot of sense
hi David my name is Sean and I've been
following the uh writtenhouse case and I
know that we've all been ragging on the
judge but I wanted to
um some someone that has a CS degree
computer science degree I've been
finding it quite alarming how
um leading to judges when the defense is
made like numerous claims about
technology
um that are completely utterly wrong so
some things and some things you can you
can kind of be like okay I can dismiss
that that's that's that's an easy thing
where the defense attorney says
um a logarithm which is a math function
what he means an algorithm sure or he
makes these claims about AI being in
technology and it doesn't have to be
substantiated at all
um and I think that's what has been so
alarming how out of touch it seems like
these lawyers and frankly the judges as
well when it comes to these things and
the fact that he's willing to make some
arbitrary decisions about the case they
based on this like magical technology
that doesn't exist
um and very well said things as well
especially with technology
um yesterday when they're trying to
explain the difference file formats
and how frankly when you're going from
different operating systems and
specifically also different in this case
software when it comes to Google or
Gmail I thought it was just ridiculous
that they had these people that so
clearly know nothing about technology
and that's what's clear and the funny
thing is they're looking at grounds for
dismissal of a case potentially it's
disturbing the fact is it's not like
it's this one side has no clue what the
heck is going on with technology it's
both of them
um and so this thing is with the
software when you send things through
Gmail
um I mean that's proprietary so it very
very much could be that they do have
some kind of zipping or altering of the
file but it's also bizarre because you
think what should be done
um and I would have assumed like this
would have been a common place which
we're going to share some technology you
should be sharing like a file hash which
is to say it's the exact as an as is the
exact file that was sent and received
exactly um and I guess I was just so
I've been so alarmed because normally
when I look at cases of the Supreme
Court cases how how much of a frankly uh
[ __ ] show this has been because there's
not these restrictions and there's not
these basic like fundamental oh yes
there's a way to like verify things
um and it's it's really just a spectacle
and it's it's quite depressing and I
know I could speak with Ad nauseam but
uh think free time I nominate that
potentially for the voicemail of the
Year very very accurately assessing the
disturbing nature of and and you know
the problem is it's not just that
they're all kind of Clueless like I
don't know if you guys remember there
was this funny moment yesterday where
assistant district attorney Jim Krause
said you know your honor if I could do
the things they're accusing me of doing
I would have a much better job which was
really funny but at the same time it's
he's also saying we don't even have the
capacity to trick them in the way that
they're saying that we tricked them but
it's that the defense has done a far
better job
of playing off of the judge's
incompetence technologically
to their benefit to their benefit
your show is like MSNBC without type 2
diabetes commercials okay can you please
address the comment that Michael
Matthias keeps posting the man who
survived being shot by Kyle Rittenhouse
I'm guessing you I'm guessing you're
talking about the Gage gross kreutz
thing there's nothing to address it's
like okay yeah the the Rosenbaum charge
has nothing to do with that I I mean
what what do you want me to address it's
already been dealt with in court
um Christy says sorry about twitch
tossing some money to make up a fraction
with the Shaving of your mustache I'm
curious if you worked out the razor
Direction relative to your hair follicle
to limit razor burn absolutely I got
myself some beard oil and uh some
sensitive skin Aveeno gel and now I'm
shaving all properly and I've reduced
cuts and scrapes by about 90 percent
which is really really good I want to
say thank you to Danny Richter Danny
just signed up on my website
joinpakman.com and his new member number
12. looks like we have a little bit of
action here let's see what's going on
maybe another arrest
it does seem like someone else is
getting arrested yeah
there's what's happening is there's
people bringing guns very close to the
courthouse which is close to a school
so now they've got another individual
that they're examining
I guess they're letting them go maybe I
guess they checked them for a gun
someone might have said this guy has a
gun check them or something like that
uh tensions seem to be running High
let's put it that way let's put it that
way
and there are a lot more people here all
of a sudden we've been watching this and
there there's there's a lot of people
now
um in the courtroom not much of anything
happening so we're continuing to stand
by there but outside it's getting a
little bit chippy
a little bit chippy
um why am I not streaming on Twitch
could anyone in the chat answer that
because I feel like that's come up
before
uh we got banned from twitch last Monday
because of a 10 second video exhibit
that was gory
and we got banned from twitch for a
month so we had a thousand paid
subscribers now it says zero because of
that okay we have also been demonetized
on Facebook for broadcasting this trial
so that is what it is if it bothers you
that that happened I would implore you
to support our stream by signing up on
my website joinpakman.com we do an extra
show for members only every day
you can use the coupon code uncharged
pickles to save 69 that's a that's a
forever discount I get emails from
people saying sir when does the price go
back to normal never I would never do
that to you
if you get a discount you keep that
discount for as long as you want as long
as you want okay and I will thank every
single person who signs up on my website
so please do so because it's been uh
it's been a this could be like one of
our best months and sadly it's not going
to be because of the multiple bands and
Demon it is it's depressing someone
emailed me and said David do you think
you would have been better off not
streaming any of this trial and I think
the answer is yes quite frankly
um but uh but it is what it is and we're
going to be here through to the end
all right other messages
curious why haven't they brought in a
computer science person to clarify the
tech issues the judge is scared by
pickles yeah I don't know the answer to
that
I think they're detaining people with
skateboards Maybe
how could you shave the mustache I
fought for it in the streets yeah it's
gone
should be charged with something but I
don't see charges sticking he was
legally defending himself even if he
shouldn't have been there no
yeah okay I'm not charged with something
I'm not even going to deal with that
David shot out of a cannon today and he
plans to reschedule your appearance on
the atheist experience I don't even
recognize that name the name of that
show I don't know what that is
David it does bother me that twitch
banned you and Facebook demonetized you
but I can only sign up to support you so
many times what more can I do fair fair
I'm riled up on the fact you lost twitch
followers I've been an avid supporter
and have put you on several put you on
to several of my friends good job with
the case Katya he's banned from twitch
guys it's for 30 days it's frustrating
he will be back I'll donate Subs as soon
as the twitch is back up and running
yeah I think that let me see where 30
days would put us
uh one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28
29 30. December 7th is when I guess we
would be scheduled to be allowed back on
Twitch
that's what it's looking like right now
so you know it is what it is I want to
say thanks to Andy Newman Andy Newman
signing up at joinpakman.com with the
coupon code uncharged pickles uncharged
piccolos and that's new member number 13
today
uh okay let's get let's get to a few
more voicemails and I my guesses were
probably
might only be 20 minutes until we're
gonna hear something from the judge
in fact let's actually see
what's happening now on court TV the
court TV feed freezes a lot with the
authorities on any investig
ation Department also
happened last night and they said a
person who's alleging to be affiliated
with a national media Outlet was briefly
taken into custody and issued Sarah I
actually Googled the guy's name his
LinkedIn says he works for MSNBC
photograph jurors this incident is being
investigated there was no breach of
security regarding the jury nor were
there any photographs obtained this
investigation remains active and open
according to the Kenosha Police
Department so that is the news really
the only news we've heard coming out of
it this Courthouse as you can imagine
they want to keep security around these
jurors pretty tight Ashley absolutely
and you know I've read about what's the
intent what was the intent of the MSNBC
producer and the reality is I don't
think it matters what the intent is you
shouldn't be following around a jury bus
and I think the Judge has done the right
thing and I respect that this judge does
say on the record what he's thinking I
know there's been a lot of talk about
things that he's saying and doing but
he's certainly putting it on the record
chandley let's shift years to jury
questions and one of the things I wanted
to start with were just Logistics when
it comes to this is good
all there on the field have been working
around the clock because I'm just
holding up what we have and it's a copy
of one of the jury questions on the form
that they use and the importance to me
this in this is for everyone to realize
that when a jury has a question there is
a form or a format that's used it's then
signed by the presiding juror or the
four person of the juror and then it's
also file stamped right because they
wanted to be part of the record so we
know that's happened but give us more
specifics on what this jury has been
asking yes please
yeah I think it's so telling for us as
we try to
figure out what they're actually doing
back there in the deliberation room
right to see some of the forms like you
said I have them as well and and how
they're filling it out and what they're
requesting and the time that they're
actually requesting so we pulled out the
request number one and number two this
is from the first day of deliberations
the first time we heard from the jury
after they resumed deliberations and we
see that at 10 17 a.m that's when they
were requesting copies of 11 more copies
of pages one through six of the jewelry
instructions and you can see it signed
by presiding juror number 54. we don't
know exactly which juror on the jury
panel that is but we'll get a good look
at his or her handwriting on here uh but
way better handwriting than I have here
we go about four and a half hours later
in that same day they requested 11 more
copies of the remainder of those jury
instructions so it seems as though they
spent much of the day probably about
four hours or so on pages one through
six actually before they actually
started reading the rest of the document
which was concerned the charges the
elements of the charges against Kyle
Rittenhouse but those first six pages
again covered self-defense the elements
of self-defense really key here for the
defense so I just thought that was
interesting to get an inside glimpse
into what this jury has been going
through and working on and I really
appreciate they asked for 11 copies what
does that mean obviously it means that
each juror would have a copy of those
jury instructions so I think they're
being very deliberate likely and going
through the exact law that's relayed in
those jury instructions to determine
what they're going to decide as a jury I
also want to bring in now channeling
Nima Romani who has stayed with us and
can join us in this conversation Nema
what are your thoughts about the fact
that yesterday we had the jury questions
and we have those that have been filed
five different sets of questions and
today it's been quiet and we are now at
what 4 45 Eastern Time still no word
from this jury
yeah a lot of this is reading the tea
leaves Ashley and Charlie and I have
gone through this many times but this is
a difficult case we knew it from the
outset this wasn't going to be easy and
the way that the evidence came out for
the prosecution was not ideal and this
is coming as a former prosecutor so now
you have a jury who's asked for copies
of the jury instructions frankly it
should have been given to them from the
outset there's no reason there should be
one copy but now they have 12 copies one
for each drawer and they asked for
playback yesterday about 45 minutes they
were in the courtroom and they asked for
two videos and as well as the FBI
infrared video well again this is
reading the tea leaves but some of the
evidence that they asked for does tend
to help the defense so maybe this is a
speculation of course we don't know
what's going on there maybe there are
some jurors that need some persuasion
and there's folks that are maybe buying
the either perfect or imperfect
self-defense argument I can tell you
that as a former prosecutor normally a
hung jury and a mistrought is a bad
thing but in this particular case a
do-over may be the best possible thing
for the state of Wisconsin all right
chinley I want to see if we can bring up
I know that we have it available at one
point the question about those videos
Nema just referred to and what all the
jury requested and my specific question
for you hopefully we can pull up the
full screen and be able to look at that
together but what was the talk if there
is any there in Kenosha and you can see
the video that they asked to see at
Rosenbaum the gross kreutz video and
watching that in the courtroom the jury
did any any discussion Chanley just in
the last 30 seconds about that request
yeah so I think it was interesting they
requested a handful of videos like you
said Gage grosskroit's live stream video
but also request number five the FBI
aerial infrared video with the markings
on it and that controversial drone video
actually they spent about 45 minutes
yesterday afternoon
inside that courtroom alone going
through these videos as many times as
they wanted to and they have you know
this is what they wanted to see they had
all the room by themselves and it's
interesting also to me that they haven't
requested anything further today because
they could request again to watch
whatever or see whatever documents that
were entered into evidence and it's just
we haven't heard from them all day long
wow and I'm watching that video and
you're right it's a short video the
amount of time they were in the
courthouse watching this evidence over
and over I you know we don't know what's
going to happen we don't know what it
means but I still would suggest that it
means they are taking their job
seriously as we know juries do chandly
painter thank you so much for joining us
live as always from Kenosha and I know
that you're going to stay with us Nema
up next we're going to be talking about
Roddy Brian's defense and the attorney
that has made repeated attempts to get
black pastors banned from the gallery in
the McMichaels all right so now they're
going into the McMichael trial so that's
the latest they are also very much aware
of the fact that we just we just haven't
heard from anybody we haven't heard from
anybody one way or the other and um we
are only two and a half minutes if you
can believe this from entering the 24th
hour of jury deliberations in a few
minutes we are going to be in the 24th
hour of jury deliberations which is
incredible
um I have to announce some something
incredible
this is one of the biggest membership
dumps we have ever had in a five minute
period big massive dumps I want to say
thank you to the following people who
have gotten memberships on my website
joinpakman.com look at this
they're almost coming in faster than I
can read them I don't know that this has
ever happened Julie clucker
Corey Moultrie we're going to get into
some some names here that are going to
be very dicey Bradford Meyer
Philip minshall
Tony Nieto
Dijon Lawless
Drew misko
sir kills a lot Richard Lee Dom Vela
Julie no uh Noah pilvenen
Anthony Aiello and Braden Sorenson all
just signed up on my website that's 13
putting us at 26.
now that's not all
uh Lauren Lance Janet Odell have signed
up Eric McGreevy I'm feeling pretty good
about my pronunciation so far Mitchell
pop
Samantha Blinn Devin Riley is a new
member
and Stephen laparte
also a new member that's another seven
which is 34 I'm sorry 33 excuse my math
and lastly I want to say thanks to Ryan
Van
Sebastian Martins Jason Jones Yvette
rosary
and Teresa pew
who have just signed up
that's an additional five putting us at
38. and what happened if you watched the
election I was called by the biggest
people
Right congratulations sir you just won
the election it was 10 o'clock and you
looked at the numbers and I'm sure you
felt that way this election was over and
then they did dumps they call them dumps
big massive dumps in Michigan and
Pennsylvania
and uh all over if you if you take a
look okay so now a new group of people
have shown up one has a sort of
statuette of Kyle Rittenhouse which says
with K's convict killer Kyle an allusion
to KKK the guy is dressed like where's
Waldo holding a megaphone a red hat a
pinstriped Blazer of sorts and a red
scarf element of some kind
um so it's certainly starting to get
cartoonish let's see if we have any
audio
no this is an odd this is a muted feed
uh
uh and for now still no activity in the
courtroom as the sun is just starting to
set a little bit in Kenosha
and we don't know the full scope of
what's going to happen today but a lot a
lot a lot happening there uh getting
very very escalated as you can always
all imagine
um
okay I had a couple of other things here
for you guys let me make a note
there's that okay David if someone tries
bribing a juror or inquiring about
deliberation is it grounds for a
mistrial
I I don't I don't think I can answer
that
sir just sent comments about the
nationalists in Poland I hope they find
their way to you the comments not the
nationalists all right I will check it
out
David hear me out getting banned
ontovich and streaming this trial is
better in the long run it only Garners
more support and solidifies your base of
supporters well that is a message of
peace and love if I've ever heard one
don't worry David we'll support you
thanks for streaming the trial Katya
says everyone mark your calendars
December 7th we'll celebrate the Pac-Man
twitch return
uh Jen says I miss gifting Subs on
Twitch but I'll make up for it when
you're back be honest they banned you
over the illegal coupon codes thank you
sir
uh let's see I mean I mean the hang up
with Matt Dillahunty not AE I thought
you were going to be on oh yeah I was
gonna do something with Matt Dillahunty
I ended up being unable to due to I
think we had an internet outage and it
hasn't been rescheduled and I don't I
don't know if it will
would you go debate Charlie Kirk if your
fans funded the trip I don't know I mean
maybe it's just you know here's the
thing there was a time in my career
where any little thing would move the
needle you know being on like a tiny
radio show that 50 people might listen
to it would move the needle because I
might only have 25 listeners and so I
would say yes to everything but one of
the things I do a lot more now is I just
say no I say no to a lot of stuff
because it really doesn't move the
needle and I have so many different
things I want to be doing so you know
the thing about going going to the the
the west coast to debate Charlie Kirk
it's first of all if I don't want to
miss
shows right because otherwise I gotta
Miss shows because it's it's all day
it's a six hour flight out there and
then a five hour flight back so
it's three days minimum
um so how do I even avoid missing a show
and I I just don't know I mean maybe
maybe
it's I'm just kind of bored with a lot
of this stuff it's like okay yeah I get
it you know Jesse Lee Peterson Charlie
Kirk I get it I get it
uh okay keep up the good work David fun
light lighthearted question what's your
opinion of pandas I'm fine with pandas
has a verdict been reached no and if so
what is the verdict we don't know
David sir Destiny's getting more toxic
Embrace vouch the person who mentioned
Atheist Experience probably met your
canceled appearance on dillahunty's okay
yeah yeah we cleared that up
we cleared that up David could the
prosecution use the judge's handling of
the trial as a motive to appeal from
from what lawyers are telling me no
from what lawyers are telling me now I
want to say thank you to a few more
people grabbing memberships on my
website Edward mulhern just signed up
is this iada or Lada I think it's iata
helgeson has just signed up Jack
Richardson is a new member so is Ed
George
thanks to Jonathan Moody and James
carfield Kyle millipickle has just
signed up milibit also
thanks to Andre Alvarez who has signed
up as well that is eight new members
putting us at 46 and then I also want to
say thank you to Jason Watts for the
patreon pledge those count double folks
that's two and that puts us at 48 today
yes uh things are starting to build
outside the courthouse
KKK wears Waldo guys here with a
megaphone I wish we could hear him oh
let's see let's see if here we can hear
anything
no there's no Audi oh wait no this one I
muted hold on
three uh
you might be behind
just make sure there's a DVR setting
turned on
so if just make sure that you're caught
up and you're live because hey guys
this is this is the snack Squad stream
they only have 400 people watching do
you think there's any way we could
communicate with this guy and get him to
interview some of these people for us do
is do you think that would be even at
all possible I mean this is this seems
to be a small enough stream that we
might be able to actually get interviews
with some of these people right now
still the court seed is a part of this
stream it's just either you guys can
watch outside or stare at the court seal
it is very cold I've been out here a few
times I need to warm up thank you so
much Sam uh so I've been taking breaks
but I've been out here as much as I can
all right if if somebody behind the
scenes can work on that that would be
really interesting if we can get some
live interviews going on there because
it is things are getting starting to get
pretty crazy it seems that that guy is
kind of off to our right over here if
you look at where he's standing right
oh I'm seeing I'm seeing people now in
the chat saying Pac-Man is saying do
some interviews Pac-Man is streaming you
let's see if he'll mention we're live on
Facebook and YouTube
on Mercado media on Facebook snack squad
on YouTube I'm Andrew Mercado
yep snack squad on YouTube
I would love to do live interviews but
the audio quality is bad and you can't
really hear over the chat the chanting I
have the microphone right up to my I see
oh wow so you guys can hear me but it's
not the best situation for interview if
he were to step away down to the street
and find somebody with a wacky sign to
talk to that would be super interesting
we're kind of communi this is amazing
we're communicating with this guy
through the chat it's amazing but we
have the court feed attached
so the interview audio won't be good it
sounds like you're in a soup can
yeah you guys can hear me great it's
just everything else doesn't sound good
interesting
[Music]
I think it would be fascinating to talk
to some of the people down by the street
level
just building chaos there
[Music]
okay we'll keep an eye on it but if if
things get going there let me know and
we can get back to it look I'm trying to
find like
it must be one of these people right
over here right that's holding the
camera based on where he's standing oh
he's right up there actually
interesting
[Music]
I can never understand chance it's like
wait what are you saying I never know
what they're talking about it's it's
wild
uh I just don't know what it is that
that they're talking about
uh okay let's monitor this and and then
we'll see what happens other super chats
coming in do you use blue for everything
due to color blindness no
I'm not colorblind it's why Zucker made
made suckerberg made Facebook blue I'm
colorblind and it sucks cost me jobs I'm
sorry to hear that but no I'm not I'm
not colorblind
the whole situation outside the
courthouse is a clown show
set Destiny send Destiny a DM asking him
to chat I don't think he's mad he's
inflammatory he looks bored
um you know I'm we've built a nice
audience right now of 11 000 people I'm
worried if I go and talk to Destiny
right now I lose half the audience
so I don't know that I want to do that
right now
isn't it ironic Rittenhouse went to
prevent destruction but caused it and
caused destruction of life he took a gun
to feel safe but felt threatened oh wait
is something happening here let's see
okay no there's not any productive
discussion happening right there at this
point in time
uh okay so we'll continue looking at
that David can you add a matte black
water bottle to your store I have no
idea
I have no idea we could look into that
speaking of Jesse Lee Peterson is he
real or not I suffer from mental anguish
trying to figure out if he's genuine
yeah he it's it was genuine
it was genuine
is the Gathering crowd entirely
pro-conviction no absolutely not we we
saw some videos earlier I heard the
chant calzones are guilty by the way how
are the calzones
make it a calzone for dinner tonight
to see if my girlfriend's up for that
but I I haven't had a good calzone in a
long time
um
Jimmy from Philly is dumping in some
voicemails
now if that's true why are you showing
for 299 memberships on YouTube I mean
Jesus Christ it's pathetic
you know and uh
you know um sometimes you meet people
and they're just not business oriented
you know what people go
why why are the memberships so cheap how
how do you make my two two dollars
but they're 7.8 billion people on this
planet and this is sort of like you know
some people are just very much
empathy oriented some people are
incredibly good at doing things with
their hands some people are good at
different things
um
if you sell something that's a dollar a
million times it's a million dollars so
it's a very you know it's it's like what
with
okay
let's listen to the next one
Jimmy from Philly why
you claims like a year or two ago that
uh you're cutting the grass you're doing
the leaves I'm gonna need to see video
evidence to that David
no one making 124 million dollars a year
is cutting around lawn come on David so
you know what's really funny about that
um I I do my I do my own lawn yeah
um I have I've said before I have an
electric lawnmower which I love because
it doesn't you know I don't want
gasoline can you imagine having gallons
of gasoline around and then they might
spill they could set on fire I do but I
do my own lawn I typically do my own
leaves as well but this year because
it's been so warm as you know warm food
around noon because it's been so warm
the leaves really won't need to be done
into December and I'm gonna be
um I'm gonna be away basically all of
December so I admit I admit there's
going to be a service doing the leaves
this year that's absolutely true that is
absolutely true but the lawn I do myself
okay
um
and one more sort of weird commentary
from Jimmy
were you to a membership and super chess
when you when you when you unban me I
might give you another Super Chat David
but the majority of your people don't
spend a sign ascent
pathetic
I don't even know who he's criticizing
there okay I'm gonna prove to you guys I
I'm Jimmy I'm gonna prove to you this
issue with the
um unbanning okay I'm gonna prove to you
the issue that's going on
uh if I go over here as you can see here
unblock user oh wait hold on hold on
unblock user okay I'm going to click it
I'm going to show you this glitch
unblock user this will allow them to
comment yes okay now I refresh
you go back unblock user it's a glitch
I've we have five or six people we're
trying to unban I'm not lying Jimmy I
literally can't unban you I've tried to
unblock you 10 times it it's a YouTube
glitch please stop talking to me about
it I have the list our YouTube rep is
working on it can you imagine what I
have going on that I'm personally trying
to get trying to handle this issue
um
yeah just avoid getting banned that's
the idea let's see what's going on here
[Music]
[Music]
himself
[Music]
[Applause]
seems sort of like General chaos
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah the audio is pretty bad let's see
if we can see where is that taking place
having a hard time seeing okay um I hope
that people are aware that time is
getting very very tight for for a
verdict today
um any time in the next 15 to 45 minutes
they would presumably wrap for the day
which would push us into a fourth day of
deliberation tomorrow I do want to see
what's happening on court TV they had
some interesting commentary Congregation
of nothing right now now they're talking
about the killing of Ahmad arbory we are
into the 24th hour guys 24th hour of
deliberation here 24th hour of
deliberation which is incredible
um
sir I have to ask if is your lawnmower
powered by pickles Pacman Google says
your net value is 14 billion since you
were franchised in 1980 what is your
membership Drive say about that yes
Phoebe exactly
um I can never tell if Jimmy is an
unhinged Trump supporter one of your
bigger fans or one of your biggest fans
or simply a troll
has the Drone been charged with perjury
by the defense yet please don't talk to
Destiny can I get an Obama
[Music]
never stop Voices YouTube is streaming
with audio let's see what they have
going
never stop voices
oh this looks interesting yeah they're
right in the crowd let's see what we've
got
[Music]
is it snowing in Kenosha now
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I'm being told the judge is back here
we go here we go here we go something's
happening oh the judge is on the phone
oh no
all right so something is happening
everybody stand by we are on verdict
watch here let me thank people signing
up because there's so many great people
here and I apologize I've neglected some
thank yous something's happening
let's see hot calzones is a new member
by the way how are the calzones Joshua
Lee is a new member Timothy Johnson is a
new member Dominic Muller
thanks to Glenda win
Joshua straight has signed up
Jackie Kelly is a new member Kim blunt
has signed up Nancy Downs thank you
Nancy Peter chaconis has signed up
that's an additional 10 putting us at 58
also thanks to Linda who made a patreon
pledge those count double today putting
us at 60 people standing meaning the
jury is coming in they may be calling it
for the day guys they may be calling it
early I I can't imagine that there's a
verdict I think it would have been
announced in the media
this may be it for the day
oh God
that cough will not go away
[Music]
you know what the news might be
pizza is here exactly
oh thanks also to Jeffrey Holland
newest member on my website thanks
Jeffrey I really do appreciate that
that's very kind of you
oh Jimmy now understands the YouTube
glitch
yes
you've certainly put in a full day and
uh have asked to retire for the evening
which uh is fine and I'm gonna ask that
you uh is nine o'clock okay again
tomorrow
okay uh any uh questions anybody uh now
um does it pertain to your deliberations
at all
as opposed to mechanics about
whether or not
take the can you take the jury
instructions home um
um
um yikes
yes
um
um yes
um but
what is happening to anybody
yeah
um yes you may do so and um
any
um
question wow okay uh wow same rules
don't read what you're listening on any
card of the trial
and
um and don't discuss the games with
anybody and we'll see you tomorrow enjoy
the evening
wow guys
this isn't feeling like it's almost over
can I take the instructions home after
another full day of negotiation
anything could be happening anything
could be happening here
let's see if there's anything else here
that is discussed wow
um can I take them home does not signal
to me at 9 15 a.m tomorrow we're gonna
have a verdict for you the alternates in
the library
all right now they're bringing in the
alternates
thanks to Peyton Manning for signing up
at joinpakman.com with the coupon code
uncharged pickles very much appreciate
the support Peyton
thank you
I feel like the judge asks himself will
this help Kyle before he makes any
decisions
you're not the only person feeling that
way
I think it's a bit of an exaggeration
but
the records Clerk sent you a
we are going to also um look back here
oh let's see and they've said on all of
the days today being day three no we we
want to go home so okay good afternoon
the most patient people
um we're going to break for the day
and I'm going to ask you a turn tomorrow
at nine is that uh gonna be okay
and I know we're over our time uh by uh
that I talked about initially
um and um you're you're this is torture
torture
please adhere to the same rules the read
Watcher listen to any account of the
trial
and
um
don't discuss the case with anyone not
even with your fellow jurors
hey any question
okay thank you
see you tomorrow wow
imagine just having to sit there you're
not even part of the jury negotiation
deliberations
you just sit there on your laptop all
day
what a nightmare nightmare
at some point
I know it is reading manners but um
now the record would reflected I um
it's probably a bad habit to ask the
jury any questions
um and uh now you can do that you can
get away with that a lot and then all of
a sudden you learn your lesson although
I don't
think because of the Armed up but uh I
typically do that as you know throughout
the trial and uh I don't don't usually
have this situation
but anyway uh and then a second time but
anyway um
the record will reflect that when I
asked when the juror inquired if they
she could take the instructions home
which also means they take the
instructions on
uh I didn't see reactions from the state
side I did see a wang of the head by Mr
Richards urging me to say no but I did
it anyway
so did you want to make a record on it I
just I'm afraid it's going to be the old
dictionary game and they start defining
words and things like that the outside
research yeah that's my concern well
actually no because they could do that
at home without having the paperwork and
instead they have the wonderful concise
jury instructions uh that I I have to
say you know I I don't know about you
guys but I watch a little TV in in the
morning and in the evening and some of
the greatest legal Minds in the country
I'm delighted to say agree with us that
the instructions are very confusing but
um is
um I don't think it would be appropriate
for the for them to bring their notes
home no you're right about that no notes
to Gold that's correct
so no notes to go home but they may take
their no note to go home that's
interesting on their instructions I'm
gonna let them take this it's a mouthful
okay uh anything else
okay see you in the morning thank you
so folks this is the third day now the
third day of deliberations have wrapped
up let's see the coverage over on court
TV digital TV in the morning and in the
evening and some of the greatest legal
Minds in the country I'm delighted to
say agree with us that the instructions
are very confusing
is I don't think it would be appropriate
for the for them to bring their notes
home no you're right about that no notes
to go home that's correct
so no notes to go home but they may take
their instructions
if they have notes on their instructions
I'm going to let them take those okay
uh anything else
okay see you in the morning thank you
all right everyone has gone home for the
day what a perfect opportunity to have
with us Sarah schmeiser who is a
criminal defense attorney in Wisconsin
let's see the analysis special reaction
to what just happened about the jury
question and the judge saying you can
take the jury instructions home
well my initial reaction is that's
pretty shocking actually I I was
surprised
um not by the question I guess as much
as by the judge's response saying yes
you can take the jury instructions home
um he put on the record just after that
that while there wasn't he didn't elicit
any information from the state the
defense shook their head I think the
obvious concern is outside research but
also I would be concerned with and
they're not supposed to discuss the case
they're not they're not supposed to
deliberate outside the presence of the
other jurors given how long this this uh
jury is taking to make a decision to try
to reach a decision I I just think there
there must be quite a lot of discussion
going on and some differing factions let
me ask you this so here's what's typical
in my jurisdiction in my jurisdiction
here in the state of Georgia What's
typical is everything that the jury has
in the Jury Room stays in the Jury Room
when it comes to me the exhibits jury
instructions notes when they go home if
they're not sequestered when they go
home and even if they're sequestered
when they go to their hotel room they
don't get to take any of that with them
what is the normal practice or the the
regular practice I don't know that
normal is the right word but what do you
typically see in court in Wisconsin in
your experience right
absolutely the same thing that you're
describing I have never had a jury a
juror be able to take anything out of
the Jury Room
um or and and of course they're given
the warnings every night don't discuss
the case don't deliver right outside the
presence of the jury the other jurors
yeah you know the notes thing is one
thing I have a really hard time
believing that this entire time they go
home their loved ones are watching news
about the trial and the jurors are
saying excuse me I'm going to go into
the other room it is impossible for me
to believe that it is just I just don't
believe it and I know people will say oh
but they're you know
whatever uh I just I just don't I just
don't buy it I just don't buy it
um
I'm told Destiny sent me a message do we
want to do this I guess I'd be I'd
consider doing it let's see here
he says if you want to chat about the
written house stuff let me know babe
with a heart
that's weird
okay give me a call now rapping soon
otherwise
I don't really want to talk about
Rittenhouse I want to talk about what's
going on with him
it's like we've gotten the Rittenhouse
stuff ad nauseum
uh
thanks to Kathleen Butler who just
signed up on my website Kathleen thank
you I really appreciate that you're
number 63 today also thank you to
Patrick mcisaac who is a new member on
my website number 64 with the coupon
code uncharged pickles uncharged
piccolos wow
uh
so we may be speaking to Stephen Kenneth
Destiny benell II we may not I don't
know it's just like I I I'm so sick of
talking about the case you know
let's see if he calls
that was uh oh that was only a minute
ago you should see it hopefully
um
yeah I have no idea why the jury is not
sequestered I have no idea either and I
liken this super chat telegio for life
that's a perfect cheese it's it's a
really a great great cheese
I like that a lot
uh
uh let's see where is Steven
I know I'll lose half the audience but
it's like I think I'm gonna lose them
now anyway so I'm more open to doing the
destiny stuff
uh
see if he actually calls
you may be ghosting me
it's pretty ugly all everything that's
going on quite frankly
let's listen to a little bit more here
oh no they're going to a break
okay
I'll give Destiny like three more
minutes otherwise I'm probably gonna
wrap and then we'll pick it up tomorrow
Destiny's not a good person person you
have a moral obligation to no longer
engage because it would be enable
destructive behavior that seems like a
very Grand you know just I'm not you
know okay here he is let's see
he's gonna call me
should be interesting
is he even live right now
uh here we go
Kenny
Packy whoa wait that's actually not a
good word Pac-Man what's up how are you
I'm doing great how are you doing
oh man you know I don't is are we not
friends anymore
that's to be determined we'll know by
the end of this conversation I guess
yeah well the conversation may be
shorter than you might think
oh okay yeah no so here listen here's
the thing I Mike I'm gonna cut right to
the chase it's just like I'm worried
that
um you are kind of falling into a kind
of depressive black and white thinking
where any descent will not be tolerated
you are looking to have problems with
people on the left as part of this whole
like the left is going I can't stand the
left and all this different stuff when
it's like it's not even clear to me we
have big disagreements necessarily about
this case but it seems like either for
lulls or because of something that
you've got going on which I would want
to explore
um that I don't I'm worried about you
uh I mean we can talk about any of the
specific disagreements that I have if
you think that I am just hating the left
but I think that all of my disagreements
so far with the way that people have
talked about this
um case yeah I think have been pretty uh
on on point I think they've been very
substantiative but I mean if you
substantiative now that's it we should
explore that what does that mean
um like if you substantiative I think
I'm pronounce it right means that you
have a disagreement but it has something
with substance there's a basis an
important fact there it's not just uh
just like oh I'm mad because I don't
like this person or whatever right I
gotcha
um let me ask you this your Tweet last
night about me being on copium or and
with the F-bomb does that not seem a
little hyperbolic to you
no I'm actually like really triggered by
the amount of misinformation that a lot
of people are spreading relating to the
case okay so your Tweet had said
um
that the the writtenhouse defense seems
rattled by the fact that jury
deliberation is into its 15th hour and
have now demanded a mistrial over an
exhibit that is already in evidence yes
um this tweet is so unbelievably not
even remotely resembling reality well
hold on a second it's my we don't know
if the defense is rattled right we you
know we don't know one way or the other
I'm giving an opinion it's not a
question of whether it's based in
reality it's my opinion is that based on
the way that the um do you remember I
don't know have you watched the entire
trial or have you watched clips of the
trial I've not the entire thing but I've
watched many many hours of it okay I'm
sure there's been parts that I've missed
but did you see when there was a lot of
discussion about the jury instructions
um I don't know if I've seen that part
no okay if you haven't seen that you
would be unable to adjudicate my tweet
my tweet so here well I can tell you
what's wrong about your Tweet without
having seen that you can tell me if I'm
missing something okay okay
sure so you're saying that
because the the defense is rattled by
the fact that jury deliberation is in
its 15th hour that they've now demanded
a mistrial so the mistrial request they
had already requested a mistrial with
prejudice before jury deliberation
you're absolutely correct now can can I
add something to that to understand it
even further yeah
the defense asked for a mistrial with
prejudice a while ago yep for two
reasons one that they felt binger's
question to Britain house about not
having given his account was a violation
of his Fifth Amendment right number one
and number two they requested the
initial mistrial with prejudice over uh
what they said was Binger asking about
something that the judge had already
said not to ask about so that's a
request for mistrial with prejudice for
those two reasons yesterday the defense
asked for a mistrial knowing it would be
without prejudice because it's now a
different thing because they didn't want
the jury to see video what's described
as question five which is the the Drone
video
by introducing
heretofore unmentioned allegations about
they got a different version and sort of
implying that Jim Krause deliberately
sent a lower resolution version which
can be adjudicated right we can that I'm
not even arguing as to the truth or
falsity of that these are two different
mistrial requests for different reasons
one with prejudice and one without so it
doesn't stick to say they asked for it
before yes they asked for a different
mistrial for a different reason before
do you understand that so and this hyper
Ultra nuanced form of events I can kind
of believe you except well now the last
part of your Tweet is is not really
accurate either but hold on now you're
moving on to something else you're
you're hold on hold on I'm still in your
original tweet so because even if I buy
everything you said there the last part
of your Tweet was they want to mistrial
over an exhibit that is already in
evidence they're not it's it's not about
them asking for a mistrial over an
exhibit that's already an Evidence
they're asking for a mistrial over an
exhibit that they received a lower
quality version of that's significantly
different than what you're implying in
this tweet I I so let's see let's take
it piece by piece first of all I
disagree with that characterization but
I'm wondering if you mean it's just
correct but okay I wonder if you've
noticed that you you're you're you're
moving on you've not acknowledged that
the first thing you said was just flat
wrong can you just directly acknowledge
that statement you made hold on hold on
let me ask the question let me ask the
question can you ignore knowledge that
you said they already asked for a
mistrial with prejudice I told you that
was a different request for different
reasons can you say you know what David
you're right that part I was wrong on
I'm I'm not wrong on that there have
been two different requests for a
mistrial my problem isn't whether or not
there has been one or two my problem is
that if I take your Tweet as a totality
your Tweet is basically saying like wow
they're asking for a mistrial just
because the jury's deliberating for 15
hours and they're doing it over a piece
of evidence that has already been
submitted let me let me see if I can um
let me see if I can ask it let me see if
I can ask it a different way
that tweet do you concede that my tweet
is about a particular mistrial the one
that they asked for yesterday and not
the one that they asked for 10 days ago
can you acknowledge that that there are
two mistrials and I'm only referring to
one yeah I can acknowledge that but the
problem is that the second part of your
Tweet then is still not correct they're
not asking for a mistrial over an
exhibit that's already an Evidence
that's not really what's being asked
it's about the fact that they were given
a the video that was of lower quality
than what was actually submitted into
the court fine the pre-trial fine so the
so so that let's let's I will stipulate
to that
I concede that my tweet is my opinion
saying that my opinion is wrong is
different than copium
with an F-bomb when I've said all along
I believe it will be not guilty it it's
that has nothing to do with guilty and
under your Tweet is just wrong it's
incredibly misleading it has everything
to do with guilty or not guilty no it
doesn't so like they're asking for a
mistrial because they're nervous about
jury deliberation and they're doing it
for a not a good reason an exhibit
that's already in evidence why not add
an exhibit where they were provided a
lower quality version of this before
going to trial it is not even it is not
even clear that that's what happened I'm
not taking a position on the that
because it was a [ __ ] show in court when
Jim Krause is saying one thing Miss
wisco is talking about Gmail Richards is
talking about the dates they don't agree
on exactly I'm not taking a position one
way or the other on that my point is
you're wrong in what you said it's
incredibly clear what's happened they
received a lower quality version of that
file I don't know if you watch what
happened after the break I know you did
but it is clear what's happened the
defense this particular defense got a
lower quality version of the video than
what the prosecution was using that part
is clear there's no mystery there I am
not denying that they ended up seeing a
lower quality version what I am calling
into question is given that they knew
that days ago that they had the idea
from the quote from the jury instruction
debate particularly Richards was asking
questions that made them believe you
know it's conceivable that the jury is
going to go right back there they're
going to go around the room and they're
going to say it's not guilty on
everything for self-defense and that's
going to be it
that has not happened hold on a second
but I can't even get myself I don't know
yeah sure okay you're getting points out
but they have nothing to do what we're
talking about I don't know that has to
do what we're talking about it so it it
does have to do with what we're talking
about because the initial see we've got
like an in it's like a fractal branching
are you familiar with fractals
yeah but I don't think that this has
like in terms of what you're talking
about for that piece of evidence like
this was emotion that they filed on
Friday this was before jury deliberation
even began I don't know why we're
talking now about like when the jury
rules of the real guilty not guilty like
man I don't need so but it's just it now
we're like five layers removed where we
have to sort of go back the reason I
initially by the way I'm echoing now I
don't know what's going on over there
you're not what now I I'm echoing back
I'm hearing myself okay now it stopped
okay
let now let me see if I can get it like
we I just don't even know that this is
productive because now we have to go
back five levels
wait wait hold on hold on I can't let
you do this okay I'm because now I have
to move to debate mode okay I'm not
allowed to do anything I'm not allowed
to speak
you've been speaking okay but I can't
let you keep trying to obfuscate your
factually incorrect tweet by saying oh
it's so we're five levels deep oh we're
talking about irrelevant [ __ ] blah blah
no no no no no very clearly and very
pointedly your Tweet was heavily
implying that the only reason or a big
reason why the writtenhouse defense is
asking for a mistrial is because they're
rattled by the fact that the jury is
deliberating in its 15th hour and
they're they want to mistrial over an
exhibit that's already in evidence one
this particular mistrial without
prejudice was submitted before the jury
deliberation began they realized this on
Friday number one and number two it's
not about an exhibit that's already in
evidence it's about them receiving a
lower quality thing now you tried to
hand wave and go well we don't know what
happened to you no no we do know what
happened we they talked about it he said
that in the process of them emailing it
over there must have been a um this
thing got converted into a lower quality
file in Santa blah blah blah we know
what happened right that's what happened
so none of this is confusing your Tweet
is just incredibly misleading hey you
know what you you're right
okay
you convinced me you're you're right
okay well is there anything else you
want to chat about Buddy
so we both agreed not guilty as probable
I have no idea it's a jury trial
anything can happen I don't I have no
idea there could be one hold out right
now it could be a six on six deadlock
um they might be disagreeing over some
of the Lesser charges maybe they've I
know I have no ideas anything can happen
as a jury trial yeah
all right well I'm I'm really glad we
cleared it all up I just I I I didn't
realize how wrong I was until you came
on today
[Laughter]
the judge is wacky do you think he's
displayed a clear bias in this case
um I mean I think that the judge is kind
of a doofus
um and I think that the judge is not
like out to get the prosecution he's not
out to get Kyle Rittenhouse off
um but I do think that there are
[Music]
um
instances where he seems I mean listen
in terms of the Optics he interrupts and
doesn't allow the prosecution to like
even finish what they're arguing
regularly where is that wait wait hold
on why do you think that is
I'm guessing you think it is because the
prosecution is doing things wrong right
okay well my understanding is that if
the judge feels like the prosecution is
going down a line of questioning that he
doesn't want them to go down I'm not
talking about the lines of questioning
I'm saying even when the jury isn't in
the room and they're arguing emotion
he doesn't even allow the prosecution
frequently to even finish their
perspective on what it is and I've seen
him interrupt the defense once in two
weeks I've I totally disagree with that
there have been motions where the
prosecution is one on it they've
successfully argued their point and the
judges allowed things to stand like
you're now arguing a different point
than the one I'm talking about
okay the implication of your point is
that the prosecution is getting cut off
more than the defense or that the
defense is winning more motions than the
prosecution those are two different
things I agree with you that there were
some motions that the defense's position
was just wacky on obviously the judge is
not going to give every motion to the
defense so there's no doubt that you're
right there are motions where the judge
has cited for the prosecution they were
obvious motions if you looked at the
legal legal analyzes there's no
controversy there the point I was in the
middle of making when you went to a
different point was on the Optics and
the way that the judge is relating to
the two sides he's interrupting and
admonishing the prosecution regularly
whereas I saw him do it once with the
defense now that's a different point
from whether you want to argue any
particular motion which I'm glad to do
if we even care to I mean at this point
it seems like water I don't understand I
guess so the first part is I don't know
why we're talking Optics we're in court
this isn't about Optics or what looks
best on like a Twitter you brought up my
opinion of whether the judge is wacky or
whatever that's about Optics it's not
just about decisions so my problem isn't
you saying the judge is wacky my problem
is you saying things like the judge is
turning the trial into a farce
I think that if you compare if you
compare listen
if you watch the trial over the killing
of Ahmad arbory you have an
extraordinarily measured judge he's not
putting on a show he's not telling
stories for the camera he doesn't seem
to be relishing being on camera every
day but rather wants to be as minimal as
possible he is being clear when the
defense attorney starts talking about
Colonel Sanders and whatever he says I'm
listen I didn't even ask you to do this
in comparison you have the judge in The
Written House case who's singing telling
stories referring to a juror a black
that he had regularly ranting to the
prosecution and defense lawyers but he's
talking about the media he's really like
on TV he's just doing a TV it's it's
wacky in that sense yeah okay so firstly
if we want so for the first point if we
want to talk about him admonishing the
prosecution more than the defense we
need to show that this is actually
unwarranted which I don't think you'd
ever be able to do we can go back to any
of the times he has and it seems like
every time he has most people that are
watching agree that like yeah or most
people that are watching with a clear
mind agree yeah the prosecution was out
of line here or here as you've said
before there have been times where the
defense has lost on certain motions and
the prosecution is one on so it doesn't
seem like it's like an Evidence of clear
bias or he's interrupting the
prosecution more he just does it when he
feels like they're out of line or
especially when he needs to cut the
prosecution off before
um the jury is able to hear something
number one number two when you say
putting on a show or stories for the
camera I mean like judges do this
sometimes I don't know if we think that
every judge is like Law and Order or
like like I don't know some crazy like
hardcore trial you're agreeing he's
doing it you're agreeing he's doing it
but you're saying it's fine yes the
problem that's your opinion no no oh my
God no holy [ __ ] you're so dishonest
okay the problem is you're not just
presenting this as he's doing it you're
presenting it as he's doing it and then
you're saying it's way out of line or
that it's wacky or that he's putting on
a story for the camera there are plenty
of Judges you just agreed he's doing it
we're not talking about whether he's
doing it we're talking about whether
your characterization of him doing it as
being wacky or out of line is fair but
hold on a second hold on a second
Stephen wait hold on I didn't even
finish responding to all the things you
said I wrote him down so that I could
get them all out okay so there are lots
of Judges that will tell stories or
jokes or whatever in the courtroom there
are Judges that will dress you down if
anybody's been to court before you will
get made fun of or forced to postpone
your trial date if you show up
um or an initial hearing if you're not
dressed appropriately a judge will throw
you out of a courtroom sometimes like
different judges do things in a ton of
different ways not every judge is going
to be this hard line like we're here
here's the process I'm not going to say
anything like this absolutely happens
from quarters quarters to say that a
judge is telling stories therefore
there's it's like wacky or it's turned
into a farce whatever is a totally
unfair characterization the idea that
he's relishing for the camera you have
no proof of that you don't know how this
guy has run trials in the past you don't
know if he's relishing for the camera
that's an unfair characterization as
well to take his whole story about why
he has defendants draw things from uh
from a uh whatever that jar was or
whatever and say and then you only take
away from that is he called somebody a
black like okay that's also like Jesus
we're reaching I even said I mean but
Stephen you know here's the here's the
problem I'm having with this Kenny
um
you
man it's like how do I even so you know
you there's there's projection here
there's
um you know you're accusing me of this
you're I'll explain
you're accusing me of dishonestly and
narrowly framing things that you're
saying but even in what you just said
I did an entire clip saying the judge's
explanation about why he had written
house draw the numbers is eminently
reasonable it's em I agree with it I
think it's perfectly reasonable and his
bizarre it was a black thing made me
laugh and it's really wacky and you
dishonestly just acted as if I said the
entire thing was illegitimate that never
happened it never happened
you characterize it as him making the
trial of farce I mean like what what is
the impression there my impression of
the judge is that the guy is farcical
he's a goof he's wacky that's my opinion
you can disagree but where I'm getting
where I'm having a problem is you seem
unable to just be like oh someone has a
different opinion and it's essentially
meaningless to either of our lives but I
feel the need to go completely Bonkers
and like attack people and use the term
copium like I'm just one wondering why
you have this tendency it has nothing
really to do with the trial it's like I
think the guy's wacky it's just my
opinion what's the big deal
uh this this defense is like is
unbelievable to me so it's not a defense
it's I'm trying to understand where like
is it content is it just content no no
you're saying it's none of this is a
Content okay you're basically saying
like LOL this is all just a big meme
that's like what you're saying right but
this isn't just a big meme people look
to online commentators to get their
opinions about how the trial is going my
problem my worry about I don't know why
you're saying oh God is some part of
that unbelievable to you that people
watch people online to get their
opinions about the ongoing of this trial
do you disagree with that I don't
disagree that people watch content to
learn about things I agree with that
okay I don't know what I don't know what
what prompted that response time right
no I'm just saying at that part I agree
with police proceed Governor okay so the
issue is is that if it does come out
that Rittenhouse walks on every charge
there's gonna be a whole lot of
left-leaning people in this country who
have who are going to feel like wow of
course it was it was a white nationalist
white supremacist supporting judge who
was making racist jokes about Asians and
blacks who turned the whole trial into a
farce who was constantly supporting
Rittenhouse and unfairly interrupting
the prosecution these are the takes that
most people are getting regarding the
trial when the reality is the trial has
been pretty standard the judge hasn't
displayed any UNS insane out of
character Behavior there hasn't been any
like mess up of the process that's so
wrong but a lot of people are walking
away with this opinion because of
commentators like you that make
statements like this so let me ask you
then
um white supremacist judge that that
rant right if we just quote that I never
said any of that stuff so why are you
mad at me about stuff I never said you
haven't you haven't said waste
management but you're playing into this
overall narrative that the judge is
wacky and farcical and is doing things
that are Unbecoming of a judge or
inappropriate in a courtroom or I think
that's an incredible incredibly myopic
and trivializing interpretation of a
hundred hours of coverage that I've done
so you think that I'm curious then and
I'm super curious if you were to pull
your audience and you were to ask them
do you think that this judge has been
Fair equally to both sides of this trial
do you think the majority of your
audience are like yeah he's been pretty
fair
I have no idea what my audience would
say my opinion is that on the decisions
the judge has been slightly favorable to
the defense that's not like a crazy
extreme position I think the judge's
decisions have been slightly favorable
to the defense it I mean is that that's
considered nuts now
that's not how it comes across but we're
doing an entertainment show with
opinions it's like you're out you're now
you're acting now you're acting like we
have to be hey guys I believe uh
53-47 the judge and and I'm not going to
editorialize anything if the judge does
something funny I'm gonna laugh at it is
this all just a bit then is it all just
entertainment it's not just
entertainment but this is sort of like
when what's that oh God what is that
guy's name Carl Benjamin what was that
guy what does that guy go by
this is like when Sargon of akkad and I
were arguing because he felt my titles
were click bait and I explained to him
I'm picking titles that are not lies but
that will make people more interested to
see what I'm saying it's like pretending
this isn't what we do it seems very
dishonest to me
I guess I just I don't view when I'm
covering like news related stuff I don't
view it as just entertainment but I
guess if you do that explains a
difference in I guess like what we're
looking for in terms of that's called
the straw man that's called a straw man
because now you're you're ascribing to
me something I never said
okay
am I I might be wacky maybe but it
sounded to me like just early you said
that what I'm engaged in is
entertainment is that did I misread you
or you can restate that I guess if I
misunderstood is the mechanism through
which we build an audience that there's
a component where people go I'm
entertained by this so I watch it in
addition to being informed like is that
is that crazy are we arguing about like
what is water at this point there's some
there is some level of entertainment of
course that's what I'm saying I think
you have to balance that out with not
like mischaracterizing or misleading
people so the balance is the balance is
I'm not saying any of the things you
ascribe to me about a white supremacist
judge or any of it but all else being
equal I'm trying to make an entertaining
show
but do you think that entertaining show
can come at the cost of giving like a
fair and balance to you of what's
happening in the courtroom I think it
absolutely can and I don't think that
that's what's been taking place with my
coverage
you think it can come at that cost I
think that of course it can you we can
find examples of anything yeah
I'm not talking about just fighting
examples of anything I my so my guess
and I could be wrong and I think
interesting to this poll sometime
although now it might be 10 because
people hate me in your audience but like
if if you would have asked before this
conversation do you think the Judge is
being relatively fair and impartial to
both sides for this trial my guess is
that 85 of your audience would say no
that he's disproportionately favoring
the defense you're saying if I would
have done it absent any of my commentary
or what do you mean or like yesterday
before our conversation I think the vast
majority of your audience would say no
the judge is absolutely being unfair and
I think that that is the mainstream
opinion right now and a lot of like
left-leaning media coverage and then
across Twitter twitch and YouTube with
people watching this so is it possible
that it's the right opinion
it is but I haven't seen anything to
substantiate that because it seems like
when you're pushed on it you do admit
yeah he's been pretty fair for
everything so it seems like that that I
didn't admit that see I think the
problem is like I don't know you're
misstating every single thing I say
you're either trivializing it and
minimizing it or expanding it rather
than just dealing with what I'm actually
saying
okay my
said something along the lines of the
judge for the most part has been Fair
maybe there's been a couple times where
he's favored the defense but for the it
sounded like
what I what I've said is on Optics and
the way that he runs the courtroom I
think the Judge is wacky and doofusy and
off color and all those different things
in addition separate from that in terms
of the decisions he's made I think his
decisions have favored the defense
while he has made decisions that
anecdote individually are uh sometimes
for the prosecution sometimes for the
defense it's just you seem to be because
I'm not speaking hyperbolically you seem
to be interpreting it as me saying
there's nothing to talk about here I
think the Judge has been favorable to
the defense but not 99 to one
sure do you I'm so I'm curious then I
guess since now we're going to take a
hyper noise Point like in what case do
you think he's been he's favored do you
think he's favored the defense on a
fairway or an unfair way I think that
there are examples of him favoring the
defense in an unfair way and I can give
you an example if you would allow it
sure I'm curious what do you think about
that
I now I'm I'm predicting you're going to
focus in on the prosecution sent the
defense a blurry video I'm going before
that okay so think back before that
latest thing happened
I believe that the defense has been able
to take advantage of the judge's
technological incompetence
by introducing arguments about pixels
algorithms logarithms
Etc
put the prosecution in a position to
basically have to try to explain to a
guy that doesn't understand any of this
why everything is okay and the judge is
simply out of incompetence erring on the
side of accepting what the defense says
assuming the prosecution is doing tricky
things with exhibits when it's really
just the the defense using the judges
and technological incompetence to their
favor
okay I don't know what your background
is in terms of how involved you are with
the video stuff that goes on for your
broadcast but the judge had an
absolutely perfect understanding of the
potential issue that could come up that
ruling was incredibly fair and he didn't
even necessarily rule against the
prosecution he just said that if you
want to present an Evidence in this
manner you need to have an expert
witness on him to do it that's the case
only with one piece of video but there
were endless instances okay no it's it
wasn't the issue with the video it's
that they wanted to take a video and
manipulate it in the courtroom if they
wanted to have a zoomed video they
should have submitted that as evidence
in the pre-trial not tried to manipulate
the video in the courtroom for the jury
to see that's a different thing
um yeah uh I just don't I mean listen
you're you're arguing that a guy who
looked dazed and called pixels pickles
had a perfect understanding of the
technology that's at play it's like I
feel like we're talking about what are
we talking about hold on you're
obfuscating with so many silly words
with so many wacky words whether you
called it pixels or pickles or whatever
isn't it the judge said it's not what
the judge said it was shocking to me
because he actually displayed an
incredibly sophisticated understanding
of the pinch and zoom because there are
a lot of tech illiterate people even
younger people even people in both our
audiences that that do think oh pinch
and zoom that's just like a magnifying
glass it is absolutely not there's all
sorts of software that goes into
enhancing images that might be involved
in a
um in a zoom but if you want to say that
there's not you just need an expert
witness on hand to testify or you should
have submitted that evidence in
pre-trial rather than attempted to
manipulate that video in front of a jury
on the spot okay ordinarily this
wouldn't be a big deal but when you're
talking about the difference between
walking or life in prison with no parole
has to do with how six pixels are going
to be interpreted on a zoom I'm sorry
but that is totally fair to say well I
don't know the conversation the
conversation about the Techno the effect
of technology on exhibits is 100 Fair
the place where it completely fell apart
and the judge's incompetence on the on
the matter became clear was that
sometimes they were talking simply about
still images sent from iPhone to iPhone
and sometimes they were talking about
enhanced videos and the parameters and
the conversations that apply to some of
those and not to others including
interpolation the so-called logarithms
by which they meant algorithms bicubic
nearest neighbor Etc the judge didn't
know what way was up or down and thought
some of the things being applied to some
of those exhibits applied to others he
was completely confused the defense was
throwing objections and conversations
about this one way or the other and
these were all completely different
issues different technological questions
around different exhibits and the judge
had no idea that that was going on they
were confusing email video images iPhone
maybe maybe we watch different things or
maybe I missed that must be a merchant
trial that must be my understanding is
that this was over one specific video
that the prosecution wanted to pension
this didn't have to do with emails and
all these it was over one specific video
that they wanted to pinch and zoom and
he and the defense objected and then the
judge said this seems reasonable if you
want to pinch and zoom in a courtroom
you need an expert witness to testify
what information is being added I think
that's a totally fair point especially
if whether or not you are guilty or you
walk comes down to how six or seven
pixels are interpreted on a zoom like
iPhone I think that's a totally fair
point you have fallen so here okay let
me back up for one second
I actually think we may be getting to
the end of the usefulness of this
because when I hear you say you were
shocked that the judge's incredible
understanding of Technology
I don't know Steven I'm not even sure
that there's a conversation to be had if
you were impressed by this judge's
technological comprehension that's
that's scary to me do you think it's
incorrect to say that a that a um uh
pinch to zoom could introduce new
material into a photo it is not
incorrect to say that in the absence of
actual specific conversations but the
fact that you were impressed by the
judge's technological competences is
that's concerning to me
okay I yeah I guess I don't know I I
haven't heard the judge rule on
something where it sounded like he was
totally out of his element where he
didn't know what he was talking about
really um if you feel like there was an
earlier exhibit that was unfair I mean
it's on the defense or the prosecution
to object
um if they hadn't then they didn't but
the judge's ruling now you're flopping
back to a you're you're going it's weird
because please don't say I'm flopping
I'm not flopping well you're flipping
maybe flopping is not the right word
flipping or flapping okay talking very
so you were wrong about the pinch and
zoom thing the judge's ruling there was
absolutely fair and showed an absolutely
decent understanding of the technology
involved that is absolutely true so if
you thought the judge was funnering
there you are incorrect now if you think
there was another point that I maybe I'm
not aware of what you thought the judge
was flattering or if you think that
mispronouncing pixels as pickles
um I don't know if the judge did that or
if the prosecutor but if you think
something like that shows that you're
technologically incompetent I'm sure
between the two of us there are a
million times we've mispronounced
resolution or interpolation or pixel or
whatever dude the guy the guy is
screenshotting text messages creating a
10 foot long narrow ribbon that he can't
even read on his phone in order to
preserve text messages and you're saying
that you're you're impressed by the
guy's technological know-how uh what
what you know it's outrageous
okay I don't know how to respond to that
so the judges the fact that the judge
had the wherewithal to understand that a
pinch and zoom could introduce artifacts
into a picture that's something that I
wouldn't expect a 76 year old man to
understand but he seems to have a decent
understanding of that and he said that
if the prosecution wanted to do that in
the courtroom they needed an expert
witness that is a totally fair ruling if
you don't believe me talk to anybody
that deals with photo video they'll
agree I don't know what else to say
about that if there was another time you
thought it was being unfair or
technologically illiterate I don't know
if screenshotting text messages is your
bar for that um then you can go but you
can go for it but it's a pretty freaking
low bar I mean my bar is higher it's
just you know it's sort of like uh like
printing out emails and putting them in
a file folder as it pertains to the
trial I haven't heard him say anything
that's completely unreasonable in
regards to technology really
is there anything else
is there like a specific because this
one ain't it this isn't it was there
another point that I missed where he
said something that was incredibly
technologically foolish it's not a
question of what he says it's that the
defense is taking advantage of the fact
that he can't tell the difference
between whether pinch and zoom is
relevant related to a video or a picture
uh the you know the defense it's I mean
listen if you just you've already lost
on this point why are you bringing this
up that was a totally fair objection by
the defense that the judge sustained
then the prosecution needs an expert
witness to testify that's totally fair
you have to have a different example
than that the judge so the judge said he
didn't actually understand you're
simultaneously saying the judge was very
very competent and perfectly understood
it and said bring in an expert witness
but in saying that the expert witness
needs to come in he said I'm not
understanding it you're telling me one
thing you're telling me another thing I
don't know the guy said I don't know he
said I don't understand it hold on what
he would what he meant and what he was
saying was in response so so now you
know what he meant when he said I didn't
understand it he meant I do understand
it no because what the prosecution was
saying was this is simple everybody has
pension zoom on their phone everybody
does this that was the prosecution's
argument they were arguing in favor of
and the judge said that he didn't have
the technical know-how to know one way
or another if that was true so they need
to bring in an expert witness to testify
that's I think that shows a perfectly
like competent understanding of the
complexities involved in these types of
image processing environments you first
said the guy showed an incredible
understanding of the technology now
you're saying the judge showed a great
understanding of his limitation for
understanding the technology these are
two different things you're now going
from he was smart enough to realize he
doesn't know do you really think that
these are two different points David
wait yes hold on wait okay hold on I'm
curious I just I'm just super curious do
you think that earlier I was saying that
the judge has an incredibly good and
deep technical understanding of the
intricacies yes you said you were
impressed with it you said you were
impressed with his understanding okay
okay I understand all right is there
anything else you want to talk about
do you understand
I I don't I don't think you're either
not approaching the conversation of good
faith you're trying really really hard
to just win a debate you're not
listening to what I'm saying but I mean
it could be other one I'm not sure I'm
trying to win it I didn't even want to
have a debate I wasn't the one tweeting
about copium
did you contact me or did hold on
Stephen did you contact me asking to
talk today or did I contact you
people told me in in my stream but hold
on Stephen Stephen hold on hold on hold
on people told me the same thing did you
contact me or did I contact you
I messaged you okay you responded my
tweet yeah after I tweeted at you yeah
okay so now you're saying the
conversation you started is one where
you don't like that I'm trying to win a
debate what
no when I say I don't it's not that I
don't mind an argument because then it
doesn't seem like you're having a good
faith characterization of what I'm
saying I would say the same to you
I think I've understood what you've said
pretty well I'm restating your points
back to I'm writing them down as you
talk to me but you keep jumping from one
thing to the other or bringing up things
that we previously rehashed in order to
win the point but I I don't care about I
don't think there's any winners here I
think there's all losers I can assure
you I have no interest in winning any
point or winning any bigger thing here I
really don't care my concern is
the combination of
the ease with which you seem to be
triggered by some of this stuff combined
with what I see as a desire to just
denounce the left and fight with
everybody to me seems like you're not
really in a great place and I'm worried
about you that's ultimately what it is
so I mean like we can keep running the
memes done all you want but my problem
is what means majority of the everything
you're saying right now is a meme it's
not a meme actually it's not a triggered
by misinformation I do get triggered
when people are dishonestly presenting
narratives and then you claim it's just
for entertainment or it's just your
opinion and I never said that people I
missed you did earlier people can go
wrong I never said it's hold on a second
but there's two but see you're
misstating it right there you just said
that you're me so you you J you said you
said it was only for entertainment and
it's only your opinion
hold on a second let me say what I
that's right let me say what I said I
said Sometimes you seem to get a little
more mad than it seems sensible over
something that at the end of the day is
someone's opinion this is wait you're
not even addressed the second piece of
it is I never said it's only
entertaining like you're just saying
you're mad over and over again like this
is reinforcing your point like you're
like are you mad are you mad that's what
you're doing am I mad you're saying no
no you're asking me in more words you're
saying like you say mad are you mad
that's your response to like half the
things I'm saying to you yeah because
it's not like
you know it's like I know a lot of
people and I relate to a lot of people
and
the the degree to which you're just
furious all the time is not normal to me
this isn't a response to anything I've
said I am furious on the internet a lot
it's what I've done for the past 10
years but I think that I make a lot of
salient critiques to how the majority of
people online seem to be covering this
trial and a lot of your coverage has
fallen in line with that that there have
been unfair rulings from the judge
towards the prosecution of the defense
that the trial is a farce that he's
favoring one side that he's incompetent
technologically and that's why he's
ruling on some things and I think all of
these things are just demonstrual and
true but I mean yeah I mean I I guess I
guess we just disagree you know it's
just uh I don't know the the problem is
like I'm sort of like I feel totally
fine being like hey you know what
Stephen Kenneth Destiny benel II has a
different opinion than me he came to
different conclusions than me on some
things he isn't a bad person as a result
I'm not assuming bad faith it's like
it's just not a big deal I'm not furious
with them I'm not tweeting copium F-bomb
whereas you see that I could only have
come to these conclusions either by
lying to my audience or uh doing it for
entertaining you know like it's just
it's weird that's that's the problem I'm
having where you seems this doesn't make
sense if it was the case that one of us
was lying and the other wasn't then it's
not really an argument to say well one
of us is cool with both sides and the
other is upset if the one person that's
called both sides is the one line now
I'm not saying that is the case here
that we know that to be obviously
because we disagree on that but like
yeah of course I'm gonna be a little bit
more upset and you're gonna not care as
much if I think that you're the one
that's being dishonest which I think
your Tweet obviously clearly was so I
mean I could just as easy listen Stephen
uh-huh yeah the internet my audience and
your audience are filled with people who
on on the same basis of fact think I'm
being honest and you're being dishonest
so it's I would welcome any of that
discussion if anybody wants to talk with
me go talk to Kenny that's what I'm
saying anybody wants you feel free to
because I haven't found a single person
that wants to talk about the facts of
the case and it seems to be like pretty
ubiquitous at the people that are the
most mad just haven't been watching
what's been going on or they've just
been dissecting headlines but hold on a
second hold on a second you just said
Can can I want to get through this point
without you interrupting me go for it
you just said it seems to you that the
people who are most mad haven't really
been watching the case you just conceded
you're way more mad than me by the
standard you just laid out
we would have to assume you're not
really watching the case right
I said that it seems to be that's the
whole point behind my tweet where I was
surprised because I know that you've
been watching the whole case so I didn't
understand how you were saying things
that were just factually untrue it's
just weird because like if imagine that
this was about the World Cup right
okay if I watched One World Cup game and
you watched every game and you had a
different opinion than me my initial
Instinct would be hey you know what
Stephen Kenneth Destiny Bonnell II saw
every game and I didn't I shouldn't
immediately assume he's lying a bad
person arguing in bad faith or deceiving
people my initial Instinct would be he's
watched much more of it let's see how he
came to that conclusion your reaction to
having watched parts and I've watched
the whole thing is to assume I'm lying
and arguing in bad faith it's strange to
me that's unusual I've been watching
parts of your coverage and every single
time you just seem to be constantly
relentlessly [ __ ] on the judge and
not understanding like what like any
like anything that he brings up is like
uh uh like oh like this is just him
being biased or oh the defense was
saving this because of the jury
deliberations like that's just when I
said that you know I think I don't know
if you watched when I said that on my
stream I literally said guys
I'm just throwing this out there as like
a what do you think of this sort of
thing that that's that's all it was it's
like it's not this isn't like you know I
I don't know it's I'm bored by even
having to keep talking about it it was
just like hey does anybody think this
might be a thing and a bunch of people
in my audience go no and some say yes
and that's it that's all it is
okay yeah it's not a big deal
I guess
it's all just memes in the end huh
see that's the thing you you then
trivialize it by saying it's all means
when I say to you when I listen I'm
constantly trivia it's just my opinion
it's just entertainment like I was just
throwing it out there like it's just my
opinion like you you're the one that's
trivialized the [ __ ] out of all out of
your side completely over and over again
like but it's I'm watching a trial and
get it's it's literally my opinion I'm
watching a trial and it's my opinion I'm
giving my opinion
yeah but we're not the disagreement
isn't over the like opinions can have
you're trying to make it sound like
anybody can have any opinion about
anything no I am not no no I'm against
that type of sort of post-modernist
thinking that's not what I'm saying at
all you're doing like no it's walk into
my apartment and I'm like you know what
I think that somebody replaced my
computer with an identical computer
that's exactly good has all the same
information and someone's like why do
you think that why are you attacking me
that's just like a child
wait you what are you talking about how
many times you said over and over again
this is my opinion or this is just
no but you you're angry when someone
just comes to a different it comes to
have a different opinion it's just it's
a weird level of anger I'm angry about
factually misstating things like why the
defense might be asking for a mistrial
or implying that it's because they're
nervous about jury deliberation or
employment Stephen Stephen have you have
you talked to the defense
no Okay so you you're you're saying that
something is factually wrong when it's
just an idea you have the idea that the
defense wouldn't hold bringing the
mistrial request in court in open court
and I said what if they filed they had
already filed it but they didn't push
the judge for for the decision
I don't think the Judge had read the
motion yet I think they fought I think
they were gonna they had the mind if I
went on Friday they might or might not
know that
okay but it's it's just weird when
you're like hey your speculation is
that's not something the defense would
do and I go I wonder if the defense
would do it and somehow I'm the one
who's bad because of that like
was the defense supposed to go on Sunday
to the judge's house and say hey
consider our motion right now like well
yesterday was Wednesday right so they
gave it to him on Friday Saturday Sunday
Monday Tuesday Wednesday I mean I don't
even know what we're arguing about well
like it's funny because the judge in
court literally made a statement about
people like you I think it was about
this motion where he said people in the
media are really upset that I didn't
rule in this motion on Monday and you
know I literally just got this and I
haven't even given the prosecution a
chance to respond yet I thought that
that was on the I thought so I might be
mistaken I thought that that was on the
first uh on the first mistrial request I
I think there was a second one that they
submitted on Friday that had to do with
they wanted I think it was a mistrial
without prejudice I might be mixing
these two up but but he I don't think
the prosecution had responded to this
yet hmm
I'm just saying like your narrative is
so conspiratorial
I really don't have a conspiratorial
tendency I'm very much not uh not a
conspiratorial like I I I'm that's not
my instinct my audience I think knows
that
okay yeah do you ever think there were
points where a writtenhouse was just
firing indiscriminately into the crowd
when he was shooting
nah upon seeing the videos more closely
I would say no
okay all right sorry anything else you
want to chat about or I mean listen I
think that I think that the self-defense
case on Huber is pretty obvious legally
speaking I think it's I think that if
there's a question it's going to be
about Rosenbaum that's my prediction in
terms of the jury and and I think that
there I would be shocked if there's
anything other than just not guilty on
Huber but I think that they'll Focus
their debate on uh on Rosenbaum their
deliberation
gotcha okay
do you have an OP is my opinion wrong on
that
um no you can have an opinion on
literally anything oh my opinion is that
the sky is blue because I think somebody
put a lot of food dye there a long time
ago but I think we can have opinions on
what everyone have opinions on I think
that's fine
okay all right all right well Hey listen
I love you David are you so are we like
are we fighting now or like am I like
Hassan [ __ ] now where we don't talk I
fight with everybody I love it I think
it's fun I don't hate you hey in all
seriousness I I hope that this isn't
inappropriate but you're you've never
mentioned being mildly autistic you're
not mildly autistic right I'm half
Hispanic okay when I'm 100 I'm 100
Hispanic but that's not the question I
don't know if you're Argentinian family
is the same but when my Cuban family
argues with each other they are [ __ ]
screaming at the top of their lungs
that's what normal conversation sounded
like okay
my family yeah so when I talk with my
white friends or whatever or Not that
we're white of course because we're
Hispanic we're Hispanic I know I know
yes absolutely right yeah this is this
is like a normal conversation I'm fine
I'm chill okay that's so but you're
you're you're not autistic I have no
idea I've played video games I might
have developed autism I played a lot of
League of Legends David
possible I'm not I'm not joking around
about this it sounds like you're saying
maybe you are slightly autistic maybe
that's just your opinion though no I
don't have an opinion I'm not I have no
opinion I'm asking you uh-huh I I don't
know David I'm not sure
see I can't tell if you're memeing now
seems to be a big problem in this
conversation huh
huh all right well listen I mean you
know not being able to read social cues
is a big sign of autism I know that's
what that's why I think expecting your
autism onto me
do you think I think the reason some in
my audience brought this up I'm being
very serious here is that they thought
that the the rapid escalation and
attacks were a lack of reading social
cues I think that's why someone brought
it up to me oh gotcha are there a lot of
social cues on the 180 character tweets
that people are sending out
you know what David you know would have
fixed all of this
tell me you need more Zoomers in your
own you got to tag your tweets with the
slashes at the end to get the tone tags
tweets what are tweets
tweets oh oh sorry sorry I misheard that
wait you have to do the tone tags at the
end
all right well I don't even know what
that is that's crazy but look them up
and it'll it helps people like me
understand your tone better hey so did
you move to Miami
um not yet but in a and by the end of
the month I probably will have by the
end of this month I think so yeah okay
all right well listen if you're in LA
and you'll have me I would love to get
lunch uh in a few weeks but it sounds
like you may be gone oh just let me know
when you're here and I'll have you okay
you're still going to be living here
maybe we can graphics on and he'll come
hang out with us too okay I plan to I
plan to go to the Hassan house actually
oh [ __ ] make sure you have your uh
proper identification so you don't get
shot by security but otherwise yeah that
should definitely be a lot of fun yeah
um okay but in all seriousness you'll be
in LA in a few weeks still right I
probably will be yeah yeah it's feeling
like the end of the month for Miami
might not might not happen maybe we'll
see all right good Stephen we'll keep in
touch and let's just relax let's relax
let's live together let's be in peace
you know okay I'm super peaceful super
relaxed right all right so far David
this was just all my opinion all right I
do this for entertainment so it is what
it is you know that's that's what I
assumed actually okay well hey I love
you stay safe David Deepak Pac-Man all
right there it is and say hi to Molina
for me please I'll definitely say hi to
her okay okay all right thank you
there's Stephen Kenneth Destiny benell
II
and uh wow wow what do we think guys
anybody I mean I don't even know what to
think
um
did I lose how many people were watching
on his stream by the way that must I
mean somehow I gained we were up to 14
15 000 viewers during that Destiny must
have a crazy audience going right now
let's see
1400. wait a second
1400
what about on Twitch
3 000 on Twitch what
the hell
is happening now those what
he muted me what does that mean
his audience couldn't hear me what does
that even mean
why would he why would he mute it over
there
why would he mute it isn't it isn't it
content I don't even get that
yeah I don't think we learned anything
I'm I I don't I don't think we learned a
thing from that because I'm banned on
Twitch that's crazy
well all right everybody
um thank you very much
thank you very much for joining me did
did that accomplish anything like
anything anything at all
um I guess I guess not I don't know
all right everybody we will
um we will pick it back up tomorrow
thank you everybody that does it for
today deliberations continue tomorrow
see everybody very very soon
foreign